this is Joo podcast number 415 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Ekko good
evening it was kind of a classic
southern California day and the waves
were probably like four to 6 feet not
overwhelming but just a good solid size
ground swell and it was at our
spot glassy sunny out in the afternoon
no
wind and for whatever reason which I
don't know can't understand can't
comprehend it wasn't crowded there was
no one out so just Seth and I
Stoner and we're out there surfing and
we're running
racetracks we call it surfing which
means we're just catching wave after
wave after
wave and I'm out there thinking pretty
much it doesn't get any better than this
and I paddle back out from a wave and
set sitting there and out of the blue
out of nowhere he says
how am I ever going to find
happiness which is a weird thing to say
like we're out there s you know the 38
seconds before this I was hooting and
hollering going down the line on a on an
awesome wave and now he's asking me how
am I ever going to find happiness and
look he was going through some stuff at
the time but it still kind of caught me
off guard
[Music]
because we're surfing and like I said
hooting and hollering and then he's
asking me this kind of deep
philosophical question and you know so I
said what and he says
happiness how am I ever going to find
happiness
and this is coming from a guy who was
just a a
really phenomenal human being smart
positive honest loyal and and fun too
like we're always having fun always
laughing always smiling whether we were
surfing or whether we were playing
guitar or whether we were working or
whether we were doing Jiu-Jitsu or
whether we were overseas in combat it
was always smiles and it was always good
times and so now he's out here asking
me how he can find
happiness and I said bro what are you
talking about this is it this is it here
now the Sun the
waves the ups and downs life this is it
this being
alive then I caught another
wave and he got one
and we carried
on and he continued to chase
happiness and found it sometimes
sometimes on the mats sometimes with a
guitar sometimes in the ocean on a
board sometimes in the
sky skydiving the rush the adrenaline
the speed
he continued to chase it and he died
chasing
it skydiving out of a hot air balloon on
a crisp September
morning I like to think he found
it and I know at a minimum he gave me
some but I met many people over the
years that have been looking for it
chasing it chasing happiness searching
trying to find that thing that feeling
that
emotion well tonight we have someone
here with us that's an expert in
happiness and you probably didn't know
there was such a thing but there is his
name is Arthur C Brooks he's an author
academic
speaker and a
musician and he's here joining us
tonight Arthur what did I miss what I
was trying to figure out how to describe
you author you you've written books yeah
academic you've taught and continued to
teach yeah full-time Professor speaker
cuz you speak 48 weeks a year and
musician you play used to do that but
you don't do it anymore I was a French
horn player for the first 12 years of my
career from 19 to 31 right and actually
we got connected through rain Wilson
yeah that's right who is a bassoon
player no bassoon player more more
importantly he grow 5 miles away from me
in Seattle kidding yeah yeah is that how
you guys knew each other no no we
connected about that because we were
both classical musicians no doubt we met
each other at you know State All State
band or something when we were in junior
high or something like nerd Central
we're about the same age yeah we're both
you know we then we both kind of tried
to make our way yeah bump along um well
let's start at the beginning so let's
get there um how you got here so you're
born up in Washington yeah Seattle I was
actually born in Spokan but grew up in
Seattle my whole family is from the
Pacific Northwest and what were your
parents doing what what did your mom and
dad do my mother was an artist my father
was a college professor a math professor
what kind of artist was your mom she was
a painter and was this the kind of
painter that was Selling paintings down
at the farmers market or was she
fetching millions of dollars for for
their paintings at Christy's she was
somewhere in between she was showing at
galleries all over Pacific Northwest
mostly not Selling paintings but but
occasionally Selling paintings and you
it's it's a tough life and what year was
this this is well I I was I was born I
mean I moved in the late 60s when we
moved to our place in Seattle and I grew
up in the 70s and that's when she was in
the heart of her career 70s and ' 80s by
the time and by by about 1990 she was
very ill um by the time she was in her
mid-50s she was already experiencing
some real real decline cognitive decline
and so that it didn't put an end to it
but it wasn't great was she a hippie no
my parents were very religious but they
were pretty countercultural in their own
way too they had a the great thing about
my parents is that that they were
entrepreneurs in the business of their
own lives and they both they grew up
together I mean they I mean to the
extent that they met in college when
they were 20 got married right out of
college and then built a life together
that was kind of of their own design and
that was an incredible example for me
you got to you got to build your life
your life is your Enterprise you're the
startup entrepreneur of the only
Enterprise that really matters and
that's really under your control which
is you that's the whole point and that's
really my my dad he was a college
professor that's what he wanted to do
and my mom was an artist because I mean
nobody did that from her background she
come from a working class background her
you know nobody in the history of her
family had ever gone to college she went
to college was a amateur musician found
out she was really good at Art I'm going
to make this a career and so we grew up
lower middle class but my parents were
doing their thing and I really admire
that and so what were you into so you
were into the French horn apparently
yeah from the time I was a little kid I
started on violin at 4: piano at 5:
French horn at 8 and that stuck cuz I
was good at it and wait you don't play
any instruments anymore yeah well I
stopped I stopped in my in in in my
early 30s I gave I I mean I did it for
professionally I mean I was I dropped
out of college at 19 um then took a gap
decade from college you know traveled
all over the world toured for a couple
years with Charlie bird the guitar
player um played chamber music all over
the world and then I played a bunch of
seasons in the Barcelona Symphony in
Spain then and then went back and got my
bachelor's degree by correspondence and
became a became a scientist but you're
in sixth grade or something and you
start playing French horn yeah fourth
fourth grade yeah yeah
and sports any sports you're playing uh
nothing seriously nothing I mean I
wasn't I was never that good in sports
my kids are great at sports my kids are
unbeliev because my wife was a was
actually a ranked track and field
athlete when she was uh when in for for
for in Spain when she was teenager so
some genetics came yeah they got good
genetics on her side that's so my kids
are I mean my daughter was a Maryland
state champion in gymnastics and now
plays College rugby oh dang yeah my son
was a semi-pro cyclist in high school
and then went on to the Marine Corps
dang yeah and my oldest son who has the
who's the least athletically capable was
actually a a pretty serious Varsity
wrestler oh okay before he went to
college props uh yeah good for him he's
just a hard worker yeah yeah did he did
he transition into Jiu-Jitsu he did not
we'll work on that he transitioned into
studying math at
Princeton well he's going to need to
work the rest of his body as well but
that's MTO a
MTO so as you're growing up one of the
things I I was reading in your book you
have I think the term you used was a
mystical experience at The Shrine of
Guadalupe yeah you're 15 years old tell
me about this what's going on you you
become a Catholic what so you said both
your parents were very religious what
were they they came from they both came
from Evangelical backgrounds Evangelical
Christian backgrounds so I have
missionaries on both sides of my family
my father was born in the nav nation in
New Mexico where his father ran a school
and then later his father was the dean
of students at a place called Wheaten
College outside Illinois which is kind
of the Evangelical Harvard it's very
it's a very elite place my mother grew
up as a southern baptist um in in the
Pacific Northwest of all places and and
and so they were you know really
religious but again they had this Spirit
of the entrepreneur the Spirit of the
pioneer go go build your life man go
build your life and so I would I sort of
you don't want to be sentimental about
things like religion you want to be
serious about something like religion
you get to choose once that's kind of my
theory you get to choose your politics
your choose your politics once Don't Go
Changing around and converting and being
a sentimentalist about this nonsense
figure out what you think is right and
do it does that mean that you're anti
someone changing their mind and getting
older and their views change over time
about their political view Point well
it's normal to change how you interpret
the facts but the whole idea of I go
from left to right to left to right I
mean that's just sentimentalism that
just means you're going with feelings
look you opened up with a a monologue
about your
friend who is obviously an incredibly
meritorious guy and an incredible person
but he was chasing the feeling of
Happiness don't chase feelings if you
chase feelings you're going to convert
your religion every 10 minutes you're
going to convert your politics every 10
minutes you're going to go with your
feelings your feelings are liars your
feelings will deceive you again and
again and again the whole point of a
happier life is transcending your
feelings is managing your feelings
that's the whole point I mean discipline
which is Central to everything that you
talk about is the reason that you know
all the cool dudes in America listening
to the jao podcast is because Discipline
matters and you need a coach in
discipline whether that manifests in MMA
or math what it really is all about is
Conquering yourself s and to conquer
yourself you have to conquer your
feelings and so that's the point you get
to choose but don't be bouncing all over
the place like a pinball that's just
sentimentalism and that's your feelings
managing you and that's a a sign of a
lack of discipline and that's a problem
for your happiness but also for your
Effectiveness as a person right but as
you learn new things and grow and become
older and more mature and you have an
open mind your perspective can certainly
shift absolutely no no all the you
understand the facts different way as
you get older you the wisdom that
actually comes from the the emergence of
your crystallized intelligence which is
something that tends to happen in your
30s and 40s and 50s it makes you see
things differently you're also less
rigid intellectually than you've been in
the past but that's different than than
basing your ideology and your religion
your politics on how you feel yeah
that's a different it's also strange it
seems like people are driven to make a
statement about what they believe at any
certain time yeah totally I mean it's
all virtue signaling a theater a lot of
it is which is you know once again it's
all just sort of feelings based nonsense
you know are you going to be the kind
you are you going to build your life on
purpose are you going to build your life
with a a sense of strategy with a goal
in mind to the person that you want to
be or are you going to go according to
how you feel this morning how breakfast
sits and how well you slept last night
whether your spouse yelled at you this
morning probably so and and you know I
mean we live in the world right but we
can't let that world what the world does
to us the atmosphere the environment the
ecosystem around us determine actually
how we're going to feel and therefore
create our path for us that's a
mistake yeah we don't want our feelings
to dictate our Behavior no for sure on
the contrary so so we're going back to
this mystical experience so so talk me
through this what happens so so wait a
second so you go down there are you
going to church all the time with your
Evangelical parents I grow up going to
church every week for sure and praying
every day with my with my family and I'm
a Believer okay I mean I'm a Christian
guy so you have that going on and now
you get down to Guadalupe why are you in
Guadalupe what's I was there for a
school trip I was actually there for a
school music trip um when I was a
sophomore in high school and you know
we're walking through all this tourist
nonsense you know we go through this
boring old dusty church and so I'm I'm
you know I'm 15 I want to talk to the
girls I don't want to be looking at a
church and uh we were at The Shrine of
Guadalupe a famous place for Catholics I
didn't know any Catholics so it's not
like this wasn't registering for me at
all but I was sitting in the church I
was in one afternoon it was the old
Basilica the new one is this kind of
late 70s or early ' 80s modernist
architecture the old one was a classical
construction from the from the 18th
century and the tilma of Juan Diego that
was the Poncho of the of the The Peasant
guy Juan Diego in the early 17th century
that the Virgin Mary appeared to him on
a hill outside of Mexico City now this
was an incredible thing this Apparition
of the Blessed Virgin Mary according to
Catholic Catholic Legend
or mythology or I believe truth that
that at the time the Spanish settlers
the the colonizers were having a
terrible time getting the native people
to follow the Catholic religion like
it's it's a pretty bad advertisement you
know convert or die it's like not very
compelling it turns out so the the
Virgin Mary appears to an indigenous guy
Juan Diego she appears as a Mesa which
is to say a woman of mixed race now
today you'd be like oh cool but then are
you kidding me that's like totally
subversive that's like a complete
transgression of everything but of
course that's what it takes and her her
image is imprinted on His Garment this
garment made of of cactus this and it's
called a t it's called a tilma he comes
back he shows it they shows it to the
bishop they they display it and
everybody who looks at it converts so in
the next nine years 7 million indigenous
people converted to Roman Catholicism
that's the story I mean that's that's
and then the whole story is that anybody
who looks at it is going to be affected
I didn't know this at the time I didn't
know this I was like a 15-year-old kid
I'm just there to play the French horn
and have some good times I look at it
and I couldn't get out of my head I just
looked at it looked at it for maybe 10
minutes left went home went back to my
life couldn't stop thinking about it
it's the weirdest thing because you know
it's not like that was happening to me a
lot it never happened to me before but I
couldn't stop thinking about the image
of the Blessed Virgin Mary on the
of some dude in 1609 Juan Diego and she
was looking at me now of course eyes
following you that's a technique Elvis
on velvet those eyes can follow you too
so let's not get ourselves right but I
couldn't get it out of my head and so I
read and read read some more converted
what are you reading I'm reading the
catechism of the Catholic church I'm
reading um you know the lives of the
Saints I'm just reading the Bible you
know I'm reading and and I'm trying to
understand what it is that I was seeing
and what it actually means to me and I'm
thinking of course about the rest of my
life you get one shot man and and I I
knew that maybe this was what I was
choosing or what was being chosen for me
and I'm my my adult life is laying
itself out in front of me that's what
that's what was going on through my head
you know I'm 15 so my my judgment is not
perfect at this point but I didn't know
any Catholics so I had to meet some and
where did you go to meet Catholics I
went to local Catholic Church how did
your parents feel about this they
thought it was probably better than
drugs you're your rebellion was going
deep Cav yeah know they were like H well
you know it's like all the neighborhood
kids are smoking pot so this looks like
it's and and of course you can do both
you can be Catholic and smok pot but you
know but the point is that that
was that was it was good and so and they
also had a lot they had a lot going on
my parents had a lot going on they were
you know had troubles of Their Own
and so they weren't I was you know look
in the 70s and ' 80s people teenagers
were completely
unsupervised I mean this is the era of
you know get in the back of the
stationwagon roll around on this on the
freeway 100% uhhuh I mean it was Freedom
baby and you know my mom would be like
don't come back until dinner and there
was no cell phones and so we're like
okay Mom doesn't not even literally let
us into the house until 6 so let's go
like let's take a bus someplace I don't
know my parents had no idea there was so
much Freedom which was great and
terrible I don't know I don't know what
so did you get like a mentor down at the
Catholic Church yeah the local priest a
British guy uh a British Catholic and
great guy wonderful guy father Tony hok
I remember him still and he was a sailor
and you know played the guitar smoked
cigarettes and he he showed me the ropes
he showed me the ways and and he was a
real spiritual guy and he understood
exactly what was kind of on my mind and
he said this is he helped me lay the
scaffolding for what was going to be a
Catholic existence and now I mean it's
the center of my life I go to mass every
day and how many times a week do you do
confession I I do confession once a
month I go to mass every day I go to
confession once a I'm not that
sinful so you're 15 years old do you
have a vision of what you're going to do
with your life besides being this uh
Catholic I'm be a French horn player
that's it I'm going to be the world's
greatest how much how much do you have
to practice French horn all day every
day 6 hours a day yeah five six playing
in every Ensemble that's available I was
playing pro by the time I was 15 16 all
every gig I could take had you know
lessons with the with the guys who
played in the Seattle Symphony I was
studying in the summers at Tanglewood
which is a big music festival in Western
Massachusetts and so my teachers there
were the Boston Symphony guys and it was
I was playing every competition I was
trying to win every competition it's
like it's like kid Sports at a very high
level I so you're Semi-Pro by the time
you're in high school if you're really
good at certain kinds of sports you're
playing every competition you're doing
it all day long you're completely
focused and there's some level of
natural talent and some level of hard
work it's both like everything else it's
both I mean you with hard work you can
be pretty good with natural Talent you
can be pretty good and together they can
interact to make you great do you get to
that point in music in French horn or
any other instrument where you're
looking at Fred and you know Fred he
just has some talent that you don't have
and you work as hard as you can and he
just going to he's going to win that
competition yeah and that was me in high
school were you Fred or were you I was
Fred and then I got out of my local
market you know and then I and and I I
met real Fred you know this is what
happened so my son my oldest son went to
Princeton and and uh he was a
valedictorian at his private high school
and you know the smartest kid and he got
there and like everybody's the
valedictorian it's it's a 1300
valedictorians that's what's going on
where you actually you you you you have
the sort of a collective of the people
that have this very high level and I met
people who were you know significantly
better than me by the time I left and
went pro so when you're GoPro what do
that what does that consist of well for
me it consisted of getting thrown on to
academic probation in my first year of
college because I had dropped my
required classes and was taking
Indonesian dance and and North Indian
classical drumming what were you
attempting to study I was attempting to
study music at Music Conservatory you
know up the grap Vine here in in
Valencia California place called
California Institute of the Arts okay
and I wasn't I just you know what I
wanted to do is play pro and I didn't
want to be studying and I was an
unmotivated student I wasn't ready and
so I was on academic probation I bailed
and I took a job playing chamber music
with a a group out of Maryland and we
toured you know five dudes in a van um
and we I did that for six years just
driving around in what kind of gig do
you play chamber music concerts I don't
even know what this means chamber music
is small Ensemble classical music small
Ensemble classical music and so we did a
lot of world tours but it was but it was
very very poorly paid I mean it sounds
like I did a world tour I could have a
t-shirt with a World Tour on it but I
was making $144,000 a year and driving a
van with two you know a big an oversized
Ford van with two gas tanks on it this
is the same thing that like punk rockers
do just FYI like the exact same thing
uhuh yeah no no it's very similar in
this way except that it's classical
music which means it's it's not cool
it's like it's all of it's all the
things about like you know unsuccessful
rock and roll but not also not cool yeah
that's great is there at least if you're
a punk rocker you're hoping that some
label sees you and you get signed and
you make a hit record what are you
hoping for when you're in a van with a
French horn I wanted to get to the point
where I could become a soloist where I
could play um in front of the solo
repertoire which is most of the great
composers write caneros which are the
the the solo pieces where the orchestra
is playing and The Soloist is in front
of the orchestra and I wanted to do that
for a living and that requires you to be
one of the three or four best in the
world that what you do where did you
make it kid um there's no ranking you
know it's not like but I mean if you if
you had to estimate how how far were you
from did you ever get that job no I mean
I did a lot of solo work I actually did
you know I I got a lot of solo thing but
not at the top tier I wasn't playing I
wasn't soloing with the you know the
Berlin philarmonic I wasn't doing stuff
like that I was in the top few hundred
in the world at the top of my career I
left to join a symphony orchestra in
Spain you leave college no no I left
college and I played for six years
chamber music okay got it and then when
I was 20 making $14,000 yeah fantastic
and then where are you living at this
time I was living uh part of the time in
Maryland and then I moved to I was in
New York City living with a bunch of
dudes in an apartment in um Washington
Heights
at 170th and Riverside Drive is very
sexy yeah yeah me and a bunch of
cockroaches are these people all
musicians all musicians all musicians
all trying to make it all trying to make
it and you know like technically I had
made it I mean I was actually making
making a living and I was making records
and I was getting concerts and I was
getting paid but it was just peripheral
to the kind of success that I wanted I
was just outside that all the time so I
took a job in an orchestra when I was
24 moved when I was 25 because I had
actually met a girl in Barcelona and it
was highly motivating to me I couldn't
she was you know European which means
that she didn't you know go to church or
believe in marriage or any of that but I
sort of figured I could you know and she
also didn't speak a word
English and and I and she lived in
barcelon I didn't speak a word of
Spanish but I had this intuition once
again you build your life right and you
got to go all in if you're an
entrepreneur in the business of life you
got to take big risks I mean hit it hard
do it take the risk if you're going to
fail you're going to fail right and so
I'd taken the risk by dropping out of
school or you know the Catholic thing
but okay this is the girl if it's right
it's going to happen I'm going to close
the deal and that's it for life one and
done mhm so I moved to Barcelona how do
you interact with the girl that you
don't speak the same language as
monosyllabic Grunts and a lot of hand
gestures and uh where did you meet her I
meet her I met her I was on tour in the
burgundy region of France playing
chamber music concerts and she was
studying music there okay so there's a
little common language of music music
that's kind of it she was also
unbelievably beautiful um I mean just
incredibly lovely and so we you know we
had enough you know Common Latin rooted
words or something that we could kind of
figure out that I figured out wasn't
married that was good it was a good
start um and and there's some alarming
things like yeah no I don't believe in
God and I don't believe in marriage and
you know all that kind of stuff she's
saying these things to oh yeah totally
yeah yeah but I'm like a mere
technicality no Factor yeah we can we
can that that and so and I I got back
from it was in dong in dong France I got
back and I after a week I you know we've
gotone out three times or something I
said dad I met the girl I'm going to
marry he's like great let's meet her I
said well I got the these technical
problems I mean she's doesn't live in
the United States she doesn't speak a
word of English and she doesn't believe
in
marriage and but I think I can I think I
can so I put together a plan um I went
and visit she came and visited me in New
York I went and visited her in Barcelona
a couple of times as a matter of fact I
didn't tell her but I took a job in the
Barcelona Symphony and the next summer I
moved to Barcelona she's like you moved
here mhm in the meantime she'd been
studying a little bit of English I
started studying Spanish and um it took
me two years but I closed the deal we've
been married 32 years and have three
grown kids and and our our our
communication has marginally
improved so so you go to Barcelona and
you're at the symphony in Barcelona
you're courting you're soon to be
hopefully wife yeah you're are you
getting paid over there yeah I'm making
living over there now it's good but it's
very it's kind of a it's uh it's
journeyman work it's not the path to
startom anymore I'm off the you know I'm
a waiter in Hollywood waiting to get
discovered I'm more on the path of
you're going to you're I'm doing like
drian commercials now yeah that's what
that's what symphony orchestra work is
you know and so you're like oh you're
the guy that was in the nose spray
commercial that's what it's like to be
in a symphony orchestra for classical
musician you're not going to jump from
that to soloist anymore it's game over a
little bit it's not game over it's game
paused because I'm in love and I don't
know and but it was you I tell you jao I
had this experience when I was 22 and I
was I thought I was at the top of my
game but it wasn't and the way that you
when you're in classical music the way
that you the notches on the bed post for
your career as it were it's a bad image
but is the concert Halls you play and so
I'm really going to make it when I do my
Carnegie Hall debut right so I'm 22 I
get my Carnegie Hall debut in chamber
music playing with these other four guys
and during the concert there's one thing
that I had to do in the second half for
the concert I had to talk about the
piece to the audience it's what you'd
always do we'd come out and tell them a
little bit about it so they'd be
interested in it I was incredibly
nervous as a public speaker now that's
what I do for a living but I was so
nervous so I was thinking about it the
concert was going well and as I get up
to talk about it I'm I I'm walking
toward the audience and trying to you
know be appropriately dramatic about
what I'm and I'm not watching my
feet and uh I fell into the audience in
my Carnegie whole debut and it was like
this this is a signal of something and I
and I took you know the subway back to
my apartment that night I'm like God is
trying to tell me something um and and
so I kind of knew by the time I went to
Barcelona that it wasn't it wasn't what
I thought it was going to be you know it
wasn't going to be the top of the
profession it was going to be okay I um
talk about guitar I play guitar yeah
very badly but do you enjoy it I love it
but there's um I always say you can go
to any Guitar Center in America and put
up a put up a a a sign with those little
take my phone number thing that says hey
I need a guitarist that can play this
song this song this song this song this
album and there'll be aund guitarists
that will contact you because there's a
thousands and thousands of really good
guitarists out there
but a lot most of them are waiters or
Carpenters or whatever so you got to
have some other thing you got to
basically have some creative thing that
allows you to write create music or
create something new and special is
there anything like that when you play
French horn or you're in classical music
or is it like you're constrained by the
classical music that's been written by
these other people and that's what
you're going to play and how much can
you very you know I I always talk about
um you know like Studio musicians that
are getting paid to play like you play
the note that they told you to play
that's what you play there's no
variations here varation you play what
they told you to play correct uh Jimmy
paig was like the you know the famous
you know Led Zeppelin but he was a
studio musician he played what they told
him to play and he got so good that when
he was allowed to do what he wanted to
it was awesome so when you're in a when
you're playing French horn what are the
options here the options are to play
what they tell you to play and where
you've got the job where it happens to
be if you're playing chamber music you
play what's on the score in the score
you if you're in an orchestra you play
in and you play the music in front of
you the way the conductor tells you to
play it the only time you have any
latitude is if you're a soloist then
you're playing the music you want to
play You're playing the pieces that
appeal to you the most but you're still
telling you're still playing what molart
told you to play when I played with
Charlie bird I'd played for two years
and I toured with Charlie bird the great
boson NOA guitar player he's the one
with Stan gets who brought boson NOA to
the United States in the late 50s early
60s and near the end of his life he was
he was kind of a legend and and I wound
up doing a couple albums with him you
remember Tommy Nome who was the band
leader with Doc senson of The Tonight
Show band with Johnny Carson I probably
would recognize him if I saw him he did
all the arrangements to The Tonight Show
band he he did a whole album of
arrangements for Charlie bird and some
brass players five brass players
including me and I toured with him and I
worked a lot with Charlie Burton he
taught me a lot of improvisation he
taught me a lot about what we means to
be a jazz musician that's a different
kettle of fish that was way Freer that
was that was composition on the Fly um
it it was hard because I was trained as
a classical player and so I was I was
sis Square as they come and so he was It
was kind of an exercise and futility but
it was it was helpful to my
soul because I got outside the I got
outside the uh the parameters of what
the what composers would write at that
point so when when I think of a musician
I think of a creative person yeah and
yet you're a musician but you're being
constrained by being told what you have
to play what's on the page yeah that's
right that's a weird dichotomy it is a
weird dichotomy except that a lot of
classical musicians are really not
they're not compositional artists at all
they're technicians they're super ultra
technicians and so you'll find that what
they love to do is at the highest
technical level to play Things correctly
they like to not miss notes and not play
Out Of Tune and not get behind or ahead
in the Rhythm and do everything exactly
right it's more like accounting than it
is like composition you know it's like
don't screw it up no mistakes so this
makes so much sense when you look at
classical music and classical musicians
and rock and roll people and go all the
way down to punk rock where it's like I
can play three chords and make a bunch
of noise and I'm wild that's right it's
a it's a different it's a different life
it's a different life and they're
usually different people yeah they're
called musicians and that's where it
stops and that's about the only
similarity uhhuh yeah that's right and
and you know the truth of the matter is
I would have been a happier jazz
musician than a classical musician but I
was traded in classical music I love
classical music I mean I love it I'm
crazy about it I listen to it constantly
now all day long it's weird this whole
personality thing so I I I think I did
four podcasts about this book called the
psychology of military incompetence and
it's a Incredible Book but it's written
by a guy first you know I was like a
some academic guy what does he know he's
some psychologist who's writing a book
about the military and then of course I
researched the guy and he was a in World
War II he's a British guy and he was
wounded and he was had experienced a lot
of combat right and he wrote this book
but the the the premise of the book is
that the military attracts people who
have like an authoritarian mindset often
times and people with authoritarian
mindsets that like everything orderly
and they like high high levels of
discipline amongst the troops and they
like everyone to be uniformed and
everyone to have haircuts and everyone
to behave the same way that's what they
want and they see the military they look
at the military from the outside and
they go that's what I like that's what I
want so that's what I'm going to go do
and that's what they go do and they
actually do well in that role when
there's not combat happening because in
combat people don't listen to you Mayhem
happens people aren't doing the right
things the enemy has a vote they do what
you don't expect them to do and so it's
total chaos so people that can't
improvise don't do well in actual combat
they do well in Garrison what we call
gar Garrison the military in other words
on the parade field when you're some in
the Marine Corps was out on the parade
field doing the the strict close order
drill movements there are some people
that are really good at that but they're
terrible in in actual combat because
it's Mayhem they don't know what to do
they actually there's no rule to follow
there's no rules there's no rules for
sure so it's interesting that in the
music world you can have a similar thing
where you have people that would listen
to music and be like wow I love the way
those notes are so quickly played and I
want to be a to play those notes quickly
at the right time at the right moment
over and over again very professionally
cool classical musician someone else
that saying like oh I want to express
myself and that's a different
personality and these traits come out
even in music that that's exactly right
and actually I was never happy because
of that in retrospect I was never happy
and you know I was doing it for the
wrong reasons like it was pretty good
music and I like music but I wasn't
happy being a classical musician because
I was so utterly constrained in the
reason I continued to do it is because I
was good and I wanted Glory I mean The
Limited Glory that comes from being a
professional famous fren you're not
going to get hey isn't that so and so in
the you're not going to get recognized
in the airp for Glory was this like I'll
be the Jocko willink a French horn you
know do you get uh when you're when
you're a classical musician like that
you're not getting recognized anywhere
like no one cares it depends I mean it's
just except for like or something right
yeah well yeah the only that's the only
person I can if you're famous opera
singer or something you know the there
are few people out there I mean you know
yoyo ma that's how famous he is right I
mean because you know one person I can
name yeah but you know there's other
people like you know PLO Domingo that
you've heard of and no but it's all good
it's all good this isn't my world this
isn't my world you know I never I never
try and act like I'm a a super cultured
person I'm certainly not know today
actually it's a different world because
everything's on the internet and so you
know you can get recognized as a an
author mhm you know and and you I'll do
this podcast 7 million people will
listen to it or something and somebody
will in the airport in the next few
weeks will be like hey you on jao show y
That's the new world Y where everybody's
a
celebrity so how long do you do you stay
on this path you're a musical technician
you're playing what they tell you to
play you're starting to feel like maybe
this isn't the thing to do yeah and
what's your exit strategy my wife at the
that I got married and my wife said you
actually have brain once you do
something with it you're unhappy you're
unhappy I demand that you do something
cuz you know that you I thought that I
had chosen you get to choose once right
that that was my choice she said that
was wrong that was chosen for you you
were fourth grade go choose the thing
what's the thing what's I don't know I
don't know what the thing is she says
why don't you study she was she actually
dropped at a high school when she was a
sophomore in high school to sing with a
rock band so she was a rock and roll
singer and so what was the name of the
band Atlanta Atlanta but in in espanol
what does that mean Atlanta it's just a
city and it it's just a city in Georgia
but it sounded cool right they were
pretty famous band in the 80s in uh in
Barcelona yeah they were pretty famous
we got some we got some uh recordings
yeah you you can look on YouTube and you
can see my wife at you know 18 years old
you know wearing short skirts and and
she's got some pipes on her oh she could
sing she's a great singer she's terrific
but she had dropped out of high school
so by the end of by by the time we were
in our late 20s living in Barcelona um
now married she was so you convinced her
that marriage was good yeah oh yeah yeah
what did you convince her about God that
took a little while longer but I I got
that sale too okay now she goes to mass
every day okay yeah my wife is like
she's she's completely committed to her
Catholic faith her parents think you
know I slipped her a Mickey or something
I like what did you do to her and her
parents weren't Catholic no nobody went
to mass no it's Barcelona Barcelona
everybody thinks it's some big Catholic
place it's a post-christian country 3%
of people Barcelona go to Mouse like
Denmark imagine yeah yeah for sure and
so it's completely countercultural to be
traditionally religious in a place like
in any place in Europe at this at this
point actually so uh she was studying to
finish her high school diploma when we
were in our late 20s and where are you
living now Barcelona you're still living
in Barcelona Barcelona and she's like
you kind of she's like I think you might
dig this stuff and so she taught me a
little bit of calculus just for fun cuz
she was studying and and I said this is
awesome is like doing crossword puzzles
this is and she said see you're smarter
than you thought and I said huh so I I
signed up for some correspondence
classes and got really into it I thought
to myself what year is this this is
1992 so this is male like you're mailing
no it's a fact machine and books in the
mail totally this is this is way pre-
internet yeah I was an early adopter and
uh and I started studying this stuff and
I'm thinking this is the exit strategy
and while I started studying economics I
thought this is the the most amazing
thing why because economics is the is
the social science about human behavior
in which markets work and incentives
matter and it was the whole theory of
your life as a startup it was the the
super structure the intellectual super
structure of your life as an
intellectual startup and so I studied
economics I got my bachelor's degree by
correspondence and then what was next I
was living we moved to Florida and I was
teaching in a Music Conservatory just so
I could I could fin my education you're
teaching French horn yeah at a Music
Conservatory in in boka Ron Florida so
you got like braty kids in there or
undergraduates they were okay but but it
was was like nine-year-olds but no no no
no it was it was a college and it was
but but it was a you know B Arthur and
Esther Brooks in Booker rone Florida
sounds like we're 90 right and we're
getting like metap insurance sales
[Music]
calls and and I finished my bachelor's
degree and I I go and get a master's
degree in economics at the local
University Florida Atlantic University
fine University and then at that point
I'm like yeah I'm all in man I'm ready
to go so I quit and uh to start my PhD
and we moved to Ithaca New York and I
started at Cornell doing my do you have
kids yet no we did kids actually in the
middle of my PhD how are you funding
this uh out of my pocket out of my
pocket so you'd saved up money yeah
teaching French horn yep and I was I did
my entire bachelor's degree by
correspondence for
$10,000 including the books in today's
dollars that's the 10K ba that's the way
and and people can do it I mean it might
be 20 but the whole point is this whole
idea where we need the government to
give everybody free college for $75,000
a year it's complete Insanity and it's
ludicrous and it's not entrepreneurial
and a mistake and and actually it's not
free because you got to pay that money
back by the way and it's going to take
you however many years 20 years I have
friends that are paying off their
student loans my age but a lot of people
think that the government should
actually pay for it in which case it's
also not free because you know the three
of us are paying for it in taxes you
know it's nothing's free and the whole
point is do it yourself build it
yourself don't take any debt and there's
a way to do it if you think about it
entrepreneurially yeah yeah and so I it
was very it was great I had a great
experience I also was not in a classroom
I had no indoctrination there was no
politics it was just a fact machine and
a bunch of books sitting around the
dining room table and telling my wife
that calculus is
awesome and so so from Florida Atlantic
University where you get your where you
get your original degree yeah then you
go where' you go next Cornell for a year
and then I finished up my PhD at a place
called The ran is it hard to get cor
into Cornell it is when you have a
bachelor's degree by correspondence yeah
like what okay so let me rephrase my
question how did you get into Cornell
when you had your bachelor's degree
through correspondence perhaps an
admissions officer was not paying
adquate
attention I mean when when I first you
know I I the
this main Professor that I had by
correspondence i' never met him but I
was doing really well in these classes
this guy is's like you're the best
student I've ever had by correspondence
he said you should go get your PhD I'm
like wow this things these things like
he said where where should I do it he
writes back to me this is all like
letters and he says you should go to
Harvard I'm like really he says yeah I
think you could do it so I I appla I you
know with full confidence because this
guy told me of course that I could get
into Harvard of course he doesn't know I
I I apply to Harvard I got rejected a
week I mean with complete Prejudice it
turns out their core demo is not a
30-year-old French horn player College
Dropout studying by correspondence
that's not what Harvard's in the market
for looking for you yeah so I you know I
applied so how did you get into Cornell
I I don't know I mean I think they were
cool they were they were like this is an
interesting guy this a French horn
player he built it by himself take a
shot and I did one year of the of this
sort of Core Curriculum in the you know
the economics and then I transferred to
a place called The Rand graduate school
which is part of the Rand Corporation in
Santa Monica and I worked at the think
tank I was doing theater level combat
modeling for the US Air Force beh in a
skiff during the day I was doing large
scale math modeling and then you know in
the afternoons I was actually taking my
cour work and working on my PhD so they
hired you for that job and then you got
the schooling as like a benefit a
benefit well the Ben I came in as a
graduate fellow a graduate fellow to
their PHD program and the way that I
paid for it was by working as an analyst
for the Rand Corporation doing this you
know big Sim battle simulation stuff
using a string a Unix machines and and
you know 250,000 lines of Fortran and
all that stuff and I was learning I was
learning like crazy I was learning my
math modeling I was learning and I you
know I was doing military operations
research
analysis enjoying working for the dod it
was great it was great I had a pentagon
pass while I was a graduate student I
was going back and forth I was I had an
action officer in the US Air Force a
lieutenant colonel I was doing you know
blue team red team simulation it was
very interesting I learned a ton I
learned a ton about the military what
kind of War gaming were you doing it was
looking at Future analysis of potential
conflicts and then and then figuring out
you know putting together force
deployment schedules and putting them
into large scale simulations and what
could happen under these circumstances I
developed with a bunch of other guys a
technique called exploratory analysis
where instead of saying I'm going to put
in all these specific parameters into a
model including the weather over some
country and then say here's how the
battles are going to go and here's how
the war is going to turn out we said
here's all the range of parameters that
can happen and so here's the range of
outcomes and in doing that you can
actually look at these highly complex
situations what I learned during that
time is something that my father told me
about my father was a mathematician and
he always said there's two kinds of
problems in life there's complicated
problems and there's complex problems
that sounds like I'm splitting hairs but
I'm not complicated problems are
problems that are very hard to figure
figure out but with enough brains and
computational horsepower you can and you
can solve it with perfect accuracy over
and over again like designing a jet
engine or putting together the internet
or building a toaster complex problems
are the most interesting problems in
life those are things where you you
totally know what winning means but you
can't actually simulate it you can only
live it and so no matter how much
computational horsepower you can't
predict if the Steelers going to win
this weekend you can't do it you have to
watch the game that's why we love it
love is a complex problem war is a
complex problem that's why we actually
don't know and so the problem is that
simulations that the dod runs are a
complicated simulation of a complex
problem and that's why there are was
wrong that's why they said you know at
the beginning of Desert Storm they said
we're going to have 60,000 American Dead
y because they were actually
parameterizing a complicated model using
Vietnam era data for a complex problem
that turned out entirely differently and
so what we developed a technique for was
to actually to deal with complex
Problems by looking at ranges of
possible parameters and looking at the
outcomes across spaces it could be best
case worst case most likely case we
could put we could put probabilities
across an entire range of parameters
across an entire range of outcomes and
we got all these all these academic
awards for these techniques that we're
using you know running future scenarios
in war and you guys did this in the '90s
yeah it was 1996 78 when I was finishing
my PhD yeah and apparently no one's
wanted to use any of these models for
the last 20 something years of wars that
we've had there's a lot of the good
stuff going on in the Pentagon still for
sure and they've they actually gotten
better at this exploratory analysis
since we developed the Rand Corporation
in the mid 90s but yeah it's still too
many people want the one andone solution
this is what's actually going to happen
you can't do that in a complex and
adaptive environment like war or love or
your C hat or a football game or by by
the way anything that we actually care
about but we keep trying to do it I'll
give you an example people want love and
they're lonely and so we developed
something like social media which is a
complicated solution to a complex
problem and all it does is makes us
lonelier and that's why how does that
work complicated solution to a complex
problem of Love exactly right so I want
to interact with other people right I'm
lonely I want to interact with other
people I pick up my phone I go to
Instagram or Twitter or Facebook or
SnapChat or anything else what all yeah
so I go to one of them Tik Tok and or
Tik Tok and they start they start
showing me other human beings yeah it's
an algorithm that actually that is a
simulation of The Human Experience it
sets you up with people that to have it
interact with virtually it gives you
nothing of what you actually want
there's a a there's a A neuropeptide in
the brain called oxytocin that you
actually need which only comes from I
cont and touch the reason we're doing
the podcast right now in person is
because we're looking at each other that
creates oxytocin and creates a human
Bond a human link we have a much better
conversation as a result of that you
don't get it when the complicated
algorithm simulates the social
experience which is the complex issue
that we're trying to solve this is what
we do again and again and again the
reason you know people like oh is AI
going to make us happy or unhappy it's
like it's a wrong question AI is a
complicated solution to the complex
problems of life it it's not going to
help us in the things that we really
want there's a reason I study love and
happiness because I'm in the complex
problems
business yeah the the the war thing I've
been talking about I talked about this
all the time there's so many variables
in war as you now know cuz you actually
tried to input all of them as many as
you could Poss simulate War you did War
I simulated War it's like shows how much
cooler you are than me but as soon as
someone starts giving me like relatively
solid prediction of what's going to
happen in some wartime scenario it
immediately tells me that I need to
watch out for this person because they
have no idea what they're talking about
they don't know the difference between
complicated and complex to use the
mathematical terminology but basically
it's very simple to figure out somebody
basically says let me explain to you
what being in love is all about don't
trust
them because it's the same thing is
trying to explain exactly what's going
to happen in war they don't know or
somebody who basically says look if the
if the Patriots play the Steelers this
weekend here's exactly what's going to
happen you're an idiot you're an idiot
that's actually not how Works everybody
kind of knows that's not how it's going
to work but but again like the world is
the world has just given us all these
comple complicated toaster when all we
want is complex cats cuz cats are warm
and they give us companionship it's like
I'm lonely I want a cat here's a toaster
I already have a toaster it's a better
toaster oh okay my house is full of
freaking toasters I want some cats at
least one cat one cat I need some warmth
I need some anyway you get my point all
right so you get done with this job at
at the Air Force and you get your PhD in
public policy from Rand graduate school
what's after that I took a job I I
taught for 10 years as aul as a
professor of of public administration
public policy economics and I taught at
Georgia State University in Atlanta for
three years then I taught at Syracuse
for seven years Syracuse is usually
thought to be the best public policy
public administration School in the
country and so that was a real goal was
to get to and once again I was just
trying to be you know the French horn
soloist but just in another field you
know chasing obscure Glory
again and so uh so I I I went to
Syracuse and you know did 10 years in
Academia and got my you know 10e
promotion and all the stuff you do in
Academia and became a full professor of
public policy published a million
articles that nobody's ever read did you
like that it was pretty good I got to
say I mean I it was intellectually
incredibly Rich cuz I learned a lot I
learned what I was I learned my I
learned I got my math down I got my
statistics down I became a much better
social scientist than I'd been in the
past and I got super interested in human
behavior I talked about beauty how
people absorb Beauty and why I talked
about philanthropy I did tons of
research on why people give why people
are impelled to give and and the tap rot
of those two things is happiness and so
by the end of that 10 years I was
studying love and happiness that's
that's really where my heart was and I I
published my first book on happiness in
2008 and then I
quit then you quit you quit that I I I
remember uh my my oldest daughter was
going to college and it was
like she was all caught up in the scene
in the college scene of where are you
getting your internship what tech
company are you for all these things
going on and you know she was stressed
out about get get a job there what all
this stuff and you know what program are
you getting enrolled in and all these
things going on and it was stressing her
out and you know I said hey this is just
like a weird ecosystem of the world that
you're in and no one outside that
ecosystem cares anything about this
completely right you know and when you
know as I'm sitting here thinking of you
as a French horn player trying to get to
the top of the ecosystem of French horn
players and like I can't even name
another French horn player in the world
besides you you're the only French don't
Playmore and you don't play anymore so
this is I can't tell you anything about
you know when you were in there getting
these papers published and the and look
this is the same thing with I'm in I'm
into Jiu-Jitsu there's a whole ecosystem
in jiujitsu there's people fighting get
to the top of the Seal team is the same
way there's an ecosystem the SEAL Teams
like people are trying to try get to the
top and I did this job and I did that
job and I got this award so if you are
feeling in life like you're competing
and maybe you're not going to make it to
the top of this thing that you're in you
should actually take a step outside that
ecosystem and look around because
there's a decent chance that no one
really cares about that ecosyst but this
is evolutionary psychology this is what
I this is what I talk about all day long
this is what I teach my students the
evolution is that we're hierarchical
creatures and we're we we understand
ourselves on the basis of social
comparison now social comparison will
ruin your life if you let it run out of
control and you're comparing yourself to
billionaires on that you see on social
media will be un you but you understand
Who You Are by looking around at your
own ecosystem and you want to rise in
the social hierarchy and there's nothing
wrong with that now it doesn't mean you
got to tear somebody else down but what
does that impel you to do it impels you
to be excellent impels you to live with
discipline and and that's a really good
thing I love hierarchies and I love
competition because they lead to Human
Excellence as long as we don't let them
ruin our lives and then going but going
back to what you were talking about
earlier if you are looking around in
this ecosystem and I am training to to
play my French horn and I'm doing
everything I can and I actually feel
like I'm not a I'm not going to get to
the top and B I'm not really that
gratified in playing the French horn
anymore yeah so I stopped that's why I
stopped and that that's a a piece of
advice for people look we enjoy
competition I I love competition clearly
I love competition I definitely we we
and our egos we look around we're like
well I think I can do better than that
I'm going to try that too but at a
certain point if you don't actually
enjoy this endeavor that you're in and
you're looking around comparing yourself
to a bunch of people that are fighting
in this ecosystem to be the top of it
and you don't care about it and you're
still in there fighting you're to me
that seems like a really negative
outcome in the long term it does it does
and that that's the reason
self-awareness is so critically
important you know that's why I talk to
a lot of young men I mean who reach out
to me and because of the work that I do
in in in happiness and you know the work
that I the social science work that I do
now reach out and say I'm feeling
aimless I'm feeling lost and you know
young men kind of need four things to to
to to to get happier they need hard work
they need
ambition they need a sense of the Divine
and a spiritual path and they need a
great woman or partner that's what they
need those are the four things you need
those are your Ambitions those are the
things to actually get so you know it's
like in when work bust your pick have a
sense of greatness and a lust for Glory
good but also have a sense that there's
a Divine Purpose a spiritual path in
your life and then have a great partner
who's going to kick your butt when
you're doing the wrong thing this is the
secret to success this is the secret to
get I mean there's more to it you know
I'm not going to reduce my entire career
to these four pillars and and and you
know and everybody's different and what
the Divine means is different in
different people and there's and I'm not
just you know talking about men women
too but the truth of the matter is it's
not it isn't rocket science you need to
actually be striving and struggling and
sacrificing and making progress but you
need parameters around it so you don't
ruin your life that way that's why you
need to love the Divine you need to love
another person and have that other
person love you so much that they're
looking out for your wellbeing and they
want to take care of you sounds like
some people need to train
Jiu-Jitsu uh and one thing that makes me
a little bit well let me just ask you a
question about that so you say people
got to have
ambition I just want to make it clear
that that doesn't mean that you feel
like you need to be at the top of the
hierarchy of some system or some
ecosystem or some industry because you
don't no that's not it ambition is about
progress that's what I see we are wired
for Progress now we think this is called
the arrival fallacy in Psychology the
arrival fallacy is once I get to my goal
then I'm going to just it's going to be
the best thing ever but it's not true
like I deal a lot I'm a nutrition and
fitness nerd and I deal with a lot of
people who have all these goals and they
think when I hit my my fitness goals or
or when I hit my weight goals people who
are trying to lose a lot of weight then
it's going to be really great the worst
thing the reason there's a 95% failure
rate in dieting is because of the the
arrival fallacy and the fact that it's
unbelievably frustrating and
disappointing so every day your reward
for the scale going down is the scale
going down itself and you're willing
it's much better than the cost of
actually not eating these things that
you find wonderful your goal I mean your
your reward for hitting your weight goal
is you congratulations you never get to
eat what you like ever again for the
rest of your life which is why about 25%
of people who are on a big diet wind up
with an eating disorder because they go
beyond their dieting goals because they
still want to get rewards the point
point is progress humans are wired for
Progress have a goal because you have to
have an intention you have to have
intentionality it's like a sailing trip
you got to know where you're going even
though you're going to be blown off
course because if you don't you're going
to go in circles like a cruise ship
which is depressing don't have your life
be a cruise ship have your life be a
navigation toward a particular point and
then make progress every day the
ambition is for the progress and when we
start to understand our lives like this
we get much happier and we can actually
have a a life full of goals that make
sense for us and we don't get so tied to
them that we wind up wiping ourselves
out yeah and I guess what stem me to ask
that question is so I consulting company
I work with all kinds of companies and I
would get someone and I've had now
dozens scores of people ask me this
question over the years you know I've
got Fred and you know Fred's a really
good guy he's smart he does a good job
but he you know he gets here at 9: he
leaves at 4:59 you know 5:00 the bell
rings and he's out of here right I I
talked to him about you know moving up
in the you know becoming a manager and
he he doesn't want to do it he just
where he's at and you know what what
should I do to should I people have had
people say to me like should I fire him
yeah and you know in a seal platoon
there's guys it's a bell curve just like
anywhere else and it's the same thing
with any of these any company any
business any team in the world there's
some people at the top of the bell curve
they're hyper ambitious they want to
step up they want to run things they
want to do things and there's a bunch of
people in the middle of the curve that
they want to do a good job right they're
going to get it done they're going to
show up on time they're going to do the
required work and then they're going to
leave cuz they have a family and
whatever rest they really good marriage
yeah and and that's cool and of course
you got some people at the bottom that
really don't care they want to be there
we have to address them right but I just
want to make it clear that ambition
isn't tied to your job it you can be a
person that worked for 32 years as a
plumber technician at a company at a big
plumbing company that grew a lot and you
kept working as a plumber and meanwhile
you raised five kids or you did all
these other things you and you just
didn't want to do something beyond that
inside of being an awesome plumber yeah
uh so does that make sense it's perfect
because here's the deal remember your
life is the startup your life is the
Enterprise your life isn't just your
work your life is your faith it's your
family it's your friendships for some
people it's their Hobbies it's their
avocations and and so if you just pay
attention if you think of your life as
an Enterprise and you're only paying
attention to the work part of the
Enterprise that's like actually having a
company and only paying attention to One
Division of the company it's going to be
asymmetric you're going to starve the
other parts you're probably going to be
unsuccessful as a matter of fact there
are a lot of different ways for you to
run that Enterprise you know I do a lot
of work on the trajectory of people's
careers and there's basically four
career trajectories for for different
kinds of people there is you know the
the linear path which is what we sort of
think at the Harvard Business School is
get our our students have to have that's
where you're once the only time you ever
moov from job is because it's the next
step up it's the next best thing more
power more money more you know Prestige
that's why you change but that's the
only reason you change and most likely
every four to seven years you're going
to go from one company to another but
that's only one path that's for the you
know the super hard Chargers that
actually want to get ahead in that you
know that with the seals it's the same
thing then there are people who are
called experts this is a NE a different
career trajectory it's a little bit
better every year not a lot little bit
better but I want to be able to support
my life with this I want to I want to
work to live not live to work and so you
know my dad had an expert career
trajectory he probably got a 2% wage
raise every year he you know he worked
moderate hours he didn't think he was
going to be the best university in the
world he wasn't trying to be he wasn't
chasing Glory the same way that I've
neurotically done it over the course of
my life and the result was just chugging
along little by little by little by
little there's two others there's the
was your dad happy uh he could have been
a lot happier but he had a lot health
problems my mother had a lot of health
problems there's a lot of exogenous
circumstances that made a little bit
harder um he should have been happier I
mean he did a lot of the right things to
be happier but intervening circumstances
the transitory career trajectory is one
where it your your your job entirely is
to support a particular lifestyle so if
you're like a surfer dude and that's
really what you have they want to then
you're going to be a barista sometimes
you're going to drive a truck sometimes
you're going to you're going to work to
support your lifestyle you fall in love
with somebody in Maine you move to Maine
you know whatever it is that's what
you're everybody listening to us young
dudes your mother's worried about that
have that and then the last is the
spiral career trajectory that a lot of
people have and they don't know it and
that's where your life is a bunch of
mini careers you're no doubt a spiral
Joo I mean you like did this and and
then you go on and every part Builds on
everything else and who knows you know
10 years from now you might actually
walk away from high income because there
something you really want to do when you
want to run your foundation or whatever
it happens to be but every your your
your career is a series of mini careers
of your design with a kind of a mad
scientist plan behind it somehow and
that's what a lot of people really have
and they need to be able to develop and
they can't do that unless they're unless
they're free to do that and that means
they that doesn't mean they need to be
free that the government needs to give
them some sort of benefit to do it it
means they need to be mentally free to
be able to understand that they are
entrepreneurs and they're not
constrained by somebody
else's understanding of their own career
so spiral is good spiral is awesome I'm
a super spiral and a lot of my students
are too so I teach mbas my I have 180
mbas in my in my happiness science class
at at HBS and they are um a lot of them
they're all they all come in thinking
that they're linear but they're a lot of
them are uncomfortable with it and they
don't know why and then I teach them
about the spiral career path they're
like ah I finally feels seen first time
in my life you know my parents are like
a lot of them have you know come from
immigrant families where their parents
sacrificed a lot to be in the United
States and and they feel like you if I'm
not doing something that's not
traditionally unbelievably successful
then I'm screwing up and what's wrong
with me and I'm am I betraying my
abilities and no no no no you just need
to understand yourself in a different
way you got a lot of things to do so you
know for me I've taken my career down
totally to the studs every 10 years and
I'm on my fourth career right now and
and and we can do that I mean
by the way God Bless America that we're
in we're in a system that allows us to
do that too yes indeed so you you this
is when you're writing books right you
co-authored a bunch of books the
Performing Arts in a new era gifts of
the Muse Gifts of time and money th
those things weren't Bigg best sellers
mhm uh portrait of the visual arts so
these you know this this is what I what
I was researching joo's got my whole
UA 2006 book comes out uh who really
cares the surprising truth about
compassionate conservatism yeah did
George W bush coined that
phrase compassionate conservative he's
yeah I mean he's he made it most famous
I don't know if he actually coined it
but he during his uh his uh first
election campaign he talked about being
a compassionate conservative and a lot
of people were offended by that because
they said we shouldn't have to put a
qualifier around what it means to be a
conservative m but the truth was that it
was a good thing for him to do and he's
an unbelievably good man compassionate
man I love W I mean it's just it's like
nobody's perfect but he's a incredibly
good person he did things that people
don't even know about I mean his his
initiative called pepar which was trying
to to eradicate AIDS in Africa was
unlike anything that any American
president has done before I mean it was
and it was from a republican entirely on
the basis of what was right what was
right to set other people free you know
in a far away place just because and
what basically the whole premise was
these are our brothers and sisters we
have equal dignity zero exceptions and
they're being held back by this thing
and we can we can actually do something
about it so that's what the whole idea
of his compassionate conservatism was
and you know I wrote a book in 2006 and
it changed my career how did it change
your career I was beavering away in
academic obscurity writing those books
that you first
listed the performing your arts in a new
era yeah I mean I had 40 50 readers you
know it
was and then I wrote this book which is
pretty boring and you know pretty
academic too it had a mathematical
appendix to it but it basically said all
the best data on who gives a charity
like who's given a charity who thinks
they're giving to charity how's that
different you know it's like what do I
think were the most you know generous
people they're the people who talk a
good game about generosity who's
actually giving is the whole point these
are people who are quietly giving you
know quietly supporting people in need
doing it out of a sense of of you know
what it means to be a good person in the
world it's not always the people that
you actually think and not the people
who are actually yelling in the Public
Square and you know I I I I wrote the
book I thought it would sell you know a
few thousand copies my publisher thought
it would sell a few thousand copies and
um George W bush read it when he was
president called me to the White House
to talk about it and suddenly I was in
the papers um what year was that was
2006 that all this happened yeah yeah
and I was just a professor at Syracuse
and and my life was changing I was you
know hearing from strangers and you know
I was doing these talk radio shows and
and going on television for the first
time and having to get my haircut to
figure out you know what you know like
oh my gosh and you know I had to get
coaching to be able to give an answer on
broadcast television that's less than
you know 40 minutes long and and you
have 7 seconds I know I know and it was
just it was and my my my career Never
Was the Same after that so then did you
do another book deal for gross national
happiness that was your next book that
was my next book was about the social
science of Happiness who's happy and who
is and it was just an observational
study about who are the happy people and
who are the unhappy people and what do
they what's different about their lives
and that one was completely complete
flop and so everybody thought since that
that last that first book you know was
like a big deal so the next one's going
to be a bigger deal it's a great topic
and and it was the seventh book about
happiness that came out that year oh was
brutal you know it sold hundreds of
copies
but I hope you got a good Advance based
on your on your 2006 book yeah but you
know you know how it is with advances
you know you get an advance and then you
don't earn it out and you feel
embarrassed and you know the point is I
don't know
that but I'm sure that's got to sting
yeah yeah it's stung and I actually I I
published the same year a textbook on
philanthropy and nonprofit management
and and then you know I was thinking to
myself you know I can do this and you
know write another book every 2 three
years for the rest of my career but it
was time to take it down to the studs
again so I quit and so the next move was
to the American Enterprise Institute
think tank in Washington DC dedicated a
better public policy for politicians it
was a
1938 Company formed during the Great
Depression um when economic growth was
minus 4% 25% unemployment and the whole
idea was we need actual Scholars actual
intellectuals who are not saying that
the secret to solving the Great
Depression is socialism the secret to
the Great Depression is spreading
capitalism all the way to the margins
the solution is setting poor people free
not shackling everybody that was the the
the the whole idea of the American
Enterprise Institute and it had been
around for years and years and years and
and they I became their president in 20
end of 2008 so what do what do you do
and what do they do how do they how do
they make change happen so it's a a
think tank is basically a university
without students that does studies that
are then delivered to policy makers so
that they can right legislation and and
create policy that's more aligned with
good ideas and that will actually help
people more and you know sometimes it's
effective and sometimes it isn't the
surgeon Iraq was actually a product of
the American Enterprise Institute that
idea with with Jack Kee and and Fred
Kegan um who authored the surgeon Iraq
policy which was a which was an
inflecting policy I mean it was it was a
big risk but it was you know based on on
highest intellectual ideals from both
military and civilian experts who said
this is something that could could
actually work um welfare reform um in
the late 1990s where the whole idea is
how well did they do executing the Surge
from your
perspective um so you were right in the
midst of that
cuz it was before I was there and um I
would have liked to have you know taken
credit for being the president of the
place when it was actually doing the
surge in Iraq but it was you know like
everything else it's a limited success
you know a great idea but the execution
is everything execution of the strategy
is everything I would turn that back on
you how do you think that the surge
turned out I think that the surge went
well and it definitely had a huge it it
shifted it shifted the war to a
situation where we were going to have a
positive impact and you know I just you
know there's been obviously a lot of
talk going around right now about Israel
Gaza the West Bank the whole nine yards
and you know I've talked about the fact
that we were fighting a
counterinsurgency once we recognized we
were fighting a counterinsurgency and we
needed to fight it like a counter insury
we need more troops on the ground that's
when The Surge happened and actually I
was in the Battle of ratti in 2006 and
they definitely utilized the success of
the battle of ratti to say hey look what
happens when we utilize this this
strategy right right and they utilize
that and that's one of the things that
was able to convince people that the
surge would be a good idea so brought in
more troops did what you know I thought
this was a great phrase from General
Petraeus who said we can't do Drive by
in counter Insurgency meaning you have
to get out of your vehicles you have to
go into those towns you have to go into
those neighborhoods you have to go meet
with the local populace you have to show
them that you're going to be there you
have to be willing to sacrifice you have
to show them that you're going to stay
and if you do all those things they're
eventually going to go well these this
is this is a better way of life is ahead
of us right and these Coalition forces
are willing to make sacrifices they're
protecting us and it definitely worked
it worked in the Battle of raditi we saw
a radical transformation T take place
there but it also worked in tfar it
worked in Al Kim it worked in Baghdad it
worked in solder City so it worked right
unfortunately in 2010 2011 we decided oh
we're we're done and we'll leave now and
that was not a good move because there
was still Embers of right extreme Islam
there and when we left they rose up and
we got Isis it's it's persistence and so
you know it's it's interesting because
the what the
The Surge was was a combination really
of three things
strength um uh persistence and brains
and that's what we need but by the way
this is what we need in our lives this
is what we need you got to bring
strength to Bear get into the gym
develop your body get your sleep eat
right be strong persistence work your
butt off be ambitious and brains learn
learn learn learn and use what you learn
if you put those three things together
you become Unstoppable and what when you
when you scale that to something like
strategy in the surgeon Iraq that's what
it took because if you did you only had
two legs of that three-legged stool it
wouldn't have worked if you just sent in
a bunch of guys sorry if You' only done
the persistence where we have the same
kind of pitiful force and we say we're
going to stay here for a really long
time and you know try to embed in the
culture it wouldn't be good enough and
if we actually didn't have a a concept
of what the coin the Insurgency strategy
was it wouldn't have worked in the first
place because we wouldn't had an
intellectual superstructure of what we
were trying to do so this is the idea
all of us should have a surgeon eract
mentality for our lives everybody in
particular when we're in crisis when the
people are listening to us if you're not
in crisis now you will be and
something's going to happen model your
strategy for getting out of the crisis
and getting your life on track on the
counterinsurgency strategy brains
learning using ideas persistence hard
work commitment and ambition and force
and that Force actually comes from being
strong and doing what it keep takes to
be strong and some of that is just you
know getting into the gym and eating
right some of that stopping drinking and
stopping the stupid nonsense in your
life yeah that the so I had a
conversation with one of my bosses we in
we just arrived in rat in 2006 and we
started doing counterinsurgency
operations which was not what SEAL Teams
had been doing for the previous three
years in Iraq and a few weeks goes by
and I get a call from one of my bosses
and he says you know you guys are doing
these these missions those aren't
typical seal missions we and we we
haven't seen any change in enemy attacks
so you need to go back to what we've
been doing and luckily I had just read
from cover to cover the fm3 TAC 24 which
had been released as a draft which was
the counterinsurgency manual and I I
said Hey sir with all due
respect the average counter Insurgency
takes 7 years right it's been 3 weeks
can I get some more time to see some
impact here and it was like yeah but
then again if you look at that the The
Surge started in 2008 and all of a
sudden in 2010 we're leaving like we
didn't give it the time to to we didn't
the persistence part we failed on the
persistence part and then we pulled
everyone out now we don't have the
strength we don't have the persistence
and and the thing falls apart and it's
it's terrible too because unfortunately
we in America our strategic planning is
going to be no more than four years it's
going to be no more than the next
election cycle and then it's like hey we
we said we're going to get out of that
war whatever it was we said we're going
to bring all the troops home and listen
there's no one that's more Pro bringing
troops home and not let's not be in war
than me I don't want to be in War I want
all the troops to be back here in
America that's what that's what I want
but I also realize that you got to have
peace and stability in the world and if
you going to make these moves you got to
be willing to stick through and and
continue until you actually achieve your
goals yeah there's a the reason that we
have people in around the world which is
because the world's unbelievably
dangerous and America is a great country
okay so there's two ways to not have
people all over the place and not doing
things either we decide we're not a
great country or suddenly the world
becomes like you know rainbows and and
and unicorns and dolphins you know
flying through the air wouldn't that be
great and whale songs well guess what
you know that's a it's a tough choice
isn't it I'll take what we've got and
I'll get and I'll take I'll take
stronger and you know it's
not I I didn't do it you did it but you
know I have a son in the Marine Corps
and and I've I listen to my son too and
he believes these things he believes
that we have an opportunity we have a
privilege of actually standing up for
our our values why because people have
dignity around the world and people live
under circumstances that are not as
fortunate as what we have and we're not
going to be everybody's policemen we're
not going to solve every problem but man
there is a lot that we can do and
there's a lot of strength that we can
bring and a lot of goodness that we can
bring on the basis of this strength Y no
doubt about it and so that's what you're
doing while you're at the American
Enterprise Institute you're you're
helping move policy forward what do you
present it to politicians this is what
we came up with yeah a whole lot of
congressional testimony a whole lot of
publication of books uh op-eds in the
major papers you know getting it in
front of the public eye um getting
information just in front of of
politicians as they're thinking through
what they're trying to do um getting it
in front of Business Leaders other
academics in front of journalists these
are the policy ideas that are going to
be helpful um that are going to make the
world better you know on the basis of
the free enterprise system of American
strength of you know health and
education policies that are good for
ordinary Americans of bringing
opportunity to periphery of society
trying to wipe out poverty on the basis
of opportunity and so that people can
lift themselves up and what a wonderful
world that would be and that's the the
basic ideology Behind these these highly
technical ideas that we would bring and
as you're as you're kind of moving
towards the end of that um which is
mostly fundraising by the way I me I was
it's a nonprofit organization I had to
raise $50 million a year I was out of
pure philanthropy we took no government
money from any government any place in
the world not a dime because you know we
shouldn't Force any taxpayers to to to
pay for what we think is right it's our
opinions that's the Democratic thing to
do that's sadly unusual that ideology
but we really believe in that sort of
freedom and so our donors were really
stepping up and we're you know this this
$50 million a year we were putting it
toward I was supporting 310 people doing
this research yeah it's
great You released a film yeah which is
called The Pursuit yeah which I watch
this film um and and fundamentally it's
like socialism versus capitalism that's
kind of the fundamental underlying
message of the film you you you go to
different places in the world but you
you look at India pre you know post
British rule all the way up through
1991 and all the way up through 1991
it's very socialist there's no Mobility
it's sort of and I remember these days
it's sort of the poster child of you
know poverty and slums and the cast
systems in place like it's a not a not a
nice place to be in India and then in
1991 they they kind of changed the way
they were doing things and start to
liberalize they started to Liber economy
um and really had a a huge impact
absolutely and no it's not perfect and
there's still tons of poverty but you
started to see the emergence of a middle
class and an entrepreneurial class
creating jobs and opportunity and growth
in India India and so now people in the
United States who' never been there they
think ah it's really rich it's all slums
it's all poverty you go there it's the
most exciting Place India is cooking man
I mean it's like it's completely chaotic
it's hilariously chaotic but it's a
wonderful spiritual fun interesting
hardworking Place everybody's got to go
to India it's one of the my favorite
places to go I go every single year it's
interesting we have a lot of because
it's English speaking English is the the
what the official language it's one of
the two official languages of India yeah
we have a lot of listeners from India
India is great I love India and I go you
know I I have spiritual teachers in
India and I meet with entrepreneurs in
India it's great and and by the way the
sense of humor and the food and the
sports it's all good it's all good I
wrote down a quote from the movie Set
people free let people decide what they
are going to do with their talent and
time and treasure they will
spontaneously organize in a way that
creates the most wealth yeah yeah that
doesn't mean every single person is
making every single good decision but
when you aggregate up to a to a to a a
society of people who have freedom of
movement and opportunity and a
competition of ideas good things happen
and it's not even a theory anymore I
mean we know this because if you look at
the world you know what's happened over
the world where 80% of starvation level
poverty has been wiped out in my
lifetime since the early 1970s because
of the liberalization of economies and
ideas and setting people free setting
women free setting everybody free to to
to you know live their dreams and build
their lives entrepreneurially it's just
extraordinary the world's completely
different than it used to be and the
reason is because of
Freedom you also uh spent some time in
that movie up in the Scandinavian region
yeah and you talk about the Scandinavian
dream of of well you know I think we
should everywhere should be like
Scandinavia which has these high
happiness quotients and uh really great
social welfare programs what did you
uncover there well I went to Denmark and
you know I Denmark wasn't chosen you
know at random I didn't throw a dart at
a at a map um my grandparents came from
Denmark and and uh but and Denmark
always comes out in these United Nations
comparisons and these big world
comparisons of happiness as the happiest
country but those comparisons are all
bogus because the way that they set it
up it's like saying who's got the best
music well I don't know I'm going to go
to a 100 countries and ask a thousand
people in each country how much they
like their local music and then I'm
going to say who got the best music on
the basis of that it's all nonsense you
don't compare countries this way I mean
they don't even answer the happiness
questions the same way in these
countries and so Denmark for example
when you ask them about how happy they
are they they answer that with respect
to this concept of contentment how
contented they are are now that probably
gives you jocka willink the heebie
jibbies because it's like contentment
kill me I don't want contentment I want
Adventure baby I want I want an act and
that's the reason that the will links
came my guess is they weren't landed
gentry you know they came to America as
total Riff Raff Right and started a farm
or something or worked in a factory now
look at you yeah that's the story that's
the story of America and that's the
reason that people sort into different
places and do different things so God
bless the Danes but I'm glad I'm not one
M because contentment makes my skin
crawl I don't want it and they do good
for them that's the whole point so I'm
me I sort of debunk that but I do ask
them you know what's the deal and I
learned a lot in you know that part you
know they have a system that's that's
that's very Market oriented it's much
easier to dismiss a public servant in
Denmark than it is in California I mean
you actually have uh a tax system that's
more egalitarian it's very high marginal
taxes but it's quite itarian you know we
have approximately 50% of the American
population that has no federal tax
liability in the United States and you
find that the you know the top one five
and 10% pay the vast majority of the
taxes in United States I'm not saying
that's right or wrong it's just a fact
it's a highly progressive tax system
more so in the United States than most
of Europe in that way as measured in
that way and then you ask them you know
what it's all about do you want to live
here not they all say yeah it's good
it's good you know they have a word
called Huga in Danish h y g G which is
hard to translate it's like the the Cozy
conviviality and the comfort of friends
on a comfortable couch or something like
that it's like I don't want it I don't
want it but they want it and they want
they have a highly homogeneous
population of people who have are
culturally very similar there's only 5
million of them there's 25 million pigs
and 5 million Danes so it's like it's a
small country and they and they're
they're quite the same and they have
this particular culture and the ones who
an adventure they came to America and
were my
grandparents and they they made the
willink and the brookses etc etc and so
I found that that there's a they have a
good answer for them is the way that
this turns out but it's not a good
answer for us where with a highly
variegated population 330 million people
living in chaos and all wanting
different stuff and mostly immigrant
stock that's a beautiful thing but it's
a different thing to be sure mhm
it comes through in the movie uh another
quote or another area you went to is uh
inz in Eastern Kentucky yeah you know
these These are coal miners and just
seeing what that what they're thinking
yeah totally different you got to quote
in there from FDR welfare is a subtle
destroyer of the human Spirit yeah crazy
that's from FDR totally totally no no
because it you know the whole idea that
you got to earn your success if you're
going to have dignity in life you know
you find that it's not just welfare it's
also winning the lottery or getting a
huge inheritance from Grandpa as a
destroyer of the spirit you know it's
not just that we're dumping on people
who are getting a check from the state
no it's it's not earning your way is is
terrible for people it's terrible for
happiness is terrible for motivation is
terrible for earning your success and
feeling like you're a person of dignity
and worth is what it comes down to so we
need a system where people can earn the
success you know so they can get an
education they can make progress every
every day and and this is not just your
opinion this is I'm a social scientist
you know you know and I come from a by
the way I come from a very politically
Progressive family so these these are
not the ideas these are not mother's
milk ideas on the contrary my parents
thought I was dropped on the my head a
lot because I like
capitalism I was a little surprised when
you get to the dolly llama yeah I love
the dolly llama four secrets for a happy
life Enlightenment spirituality worldly
satisfaction and wealth
yeah that's that's these are the four
the secrets of Happiness from Tibetan
Buddhism which is you know most people
don't understand but it's not just
wealth wealth wealth is in money it's
the whole idea of the accumulation of
the resources that are a marker of the
success and value you're creating with
your life is what it comes down to which
is the depth of your relationships the
the the the the relationship you have
with God it's all part of the wealth
it's the stock of love and happiness in
your life is really the wealth that
you'll accumulate if you're trying to
con you're trying to just count this in
money you're making a big mistake the
three things they point out is build
something yeah earn a living yeah serve
other people those were the things that
will give you wealth build something
build something with your life earn your
success earn a living meaning that you
are standing on your own two feet as a
human being and then and then serve
other people I mean it's sort of makes
intuitive sense but we sure are doing a
good job forgetting it look the dolly
llama it's like everybody thinks that
Dolly llama is some sort of you know
robed Marxist or something no he's he's
somebody who's taught me so much about I
love him and I've worked with him for
the last 11 years it's such a beautiful
experience for me to learn I've you know
I've learned meditation technique with
it with his Monks at the at the his
Monastery in daram Sala in the Himalayan
Foothills where I visit him every year
and so he's taught me a great deal about
what it means for me to be a Christian
man and for me to have better technique
in my meditation practice but he's also
taught me a lot about you know basic
common sense and ethics yeah I I
definitely would agree that that's what
people Envision the dolly llama is but
the Dalma llama Dolly Lama another quote
you have from him in the movie is
individuals change the world yeah I was
like hold on I know man this is what
we've been talking about I know and we
got the doy Lama saying that says that
it's it from his lips yeah for sure you
know this is a the the fourth law of
combat leadership that I teach and
learned and now teach is decentralized
command and it's so obvious on the
battlefield that if one person tries to
control everything everything is going
to be lost and the minute you Empower
people to step up make decisions make
things happen you are going to win yeah
and this just happens in business and it
it obviously it's from a from a
governmental perspective as well the
more control that's imposed on people
the worse off they're going to be yeah
this is a believe it or not this is a
big Catholic idea it's called
subsidiarity it's a fancy word for very
a very sensible idea subsidiar is always
push power down to its lowest possible
level now sometimes it's not at the
level of the individual I mean sometimes
you got to say everybody go do this but
if it's a a decision that can be made at
the state don't make it at the federal
level if it can be made at the city
don't make it at the state level if it
can be made by a community don't make it
at the city level if it could be made by
a family leave the community out of it
it can be made by the individual then
they have to work together in the family
to get it done and if you're in a
company of Marines if you're in your
platoon level sometimes has to do
something with platoon command but
sometimes you're in a situation where
power needs to be pushed down to the
individual where it actually becomes
most effective and that's how we should
live our lives quite frankly that's how
we should be thinking about our society
and that's when things work best is when
we're empowered that's subsidiarity that
ancient Catholic that medieval Catholic
philosophical notion sure sounds sounds
good to me
today um you can watch that movie on
YouTube by the way once again it's
called The Pursuit and it's free on
YouTube next book
2019 love your enemies interesting yeah
I really like this idea talk to me about
what's the premise behind love your
enemies well love your enemies is the
most transgressive idea in the history
of civilization and so this comes as you
know anybody who's listening who's
either aware of or practicing the
Christian faith this comes from the the
gospel of St Matthew the 5th chapter the
the 44th verse where Jesus is giving The
Sermon on the Mount and he's given all
these crazy ideas I mean it's like
people are going their minds are being
blown by this Rabbi and he says today
you know you have heard that that you
should love your friends and hate your
enemies but today I give you a new
teaching love your enemies pray for
those who persecute you and people start
just walking off right like no way man
that is the most transgressive teaching
in ever why because it's the most
pragmatic teaching that is the source of
true power Jesus didn't say like your
enemies that's
sentimentality look you like somebody
because you like somebody I like I like
you jao because you're awesome right but
even if I didn't the job is for me to
love you and even if we're at War and
you're on the other side I'm still
called to love you what does that mean
that's I mean it's like blowing my mind
it's just blowing my mind but the whole
point is that's total power because you
can only redeem your enemy when you love
your enemy and your and to love is to to
wield the good of the other to make a
commitment to do so notwithstanding your
feelings you want to discipline your
feelings you want to discipline the will
love people notwithstanding your
feelings that's huge and that's what
Jesus was teaching Jesus was teaching
the most muscular kind of philosophy
ever in that and so the question is are
we going to do it or not you want Power
love your enemies it doesn't mean you
got to have them over for dinner it it
doesn't mean you have to give them your
money what it means is you have to you
will their good as them and act as such
even if they don't like it which is by
the way how you rais teenagers you and I
have raised teenagers and and you know
they're they're acting like your enemies
sometimes and you're loving them by do
by willing their good even when they
don't want
it one of my friends is a devout
Catholic and one of the biggest
challenges he has that he States is like
we really hard for me was praying for
Osama Bin Laden yeah totally totally and
again you know you know your military um
my son is a you know he's a combat
marine and we've talked about this he's
a Catholic he's a churchgoing cath my
kids go to mass and they're all Church
going Catholics I said Carlos what does
it mean what does it mean for you to
love your enemies and you know he says
well in the Marines you were not taught
to we're sometimes taught to kill our
enemies I say are those two ideas
incompatible can you will their good and
and and the truth is I don't know how to
sort out that that's a that's a a
gordian knot that's a really really
tough one but I can tell you in my
ordinary life I have to do hard things
all the time that people aren't going to
life like but I will not hate my enemies
I I refuse to hate my enemies I will
will their good not withstanding the
fact that I have to do things that are
that they don't think are necessarily in
their interest like I've been a boss
I've had to fire people I've had to say
goodbye to people who wanted their jobs
but if they're not a fit for the company
I'm not willing they're good by doing
this I'm willing their convenience you
know I'm willing the easiest possible
path for them and and I have to tell you
because you've holy mackerel I can't
even imagine the decisions you've had to
make that went against the will of a lot
of people but it was for the good is
that fair that is fair that is
fair um you're at this point this is
2019 this book comes out now you're
you're also teaching it this is when you
start teaching at Harvard this is right
before I left the American entprise
Institute and I had I had said I had
announced a year and a half in advance
that I was going to retire as
CEO um you got when you're running
something when you're the boss um you
have two choices about leaving you can
leave before you're ready or you can
leave on somebody else's terms there's
only two
choices and uh I don't like either so
I'm going to leave before I'm ready
because I sure as heck don't want to
leave on somebody else's terms if you
hang around long enough you're going to
leave on somebody else terms so I
resigned when I was 55 and this was
taking it down to the studs again Bas
taking your career down to the studs
down to the studs we're going to start
again yep yep what was your what was
your
plan my plan was I was I mean I thought
I prayed about it a lot um because
because this is a a philosophical
concept called discernment whenever you
have a a lot of people listening to us
right now they've got to do I ask that
girl to marry me um do I go back to
school um do I change jobs they're
they're Discerning something discernment
takes work don't wait for inspiration to
flash because it won't you'll just hang
around and and then you'll be forced to
make a decision it might not be the
right one do the work and to do the work
you start basically making lists of pros
and cons and you have to be thinking
about something specifically usually 15
minutes a day I recommend I'll put
people on a discernment program think
about the decision you're making but
really think deeply about it for 15
minutes a day for 30 days and you will
have incredible Enlightenment about this
that You' never had before because
you'll have you won't have the decision
necessarily but you'll be able you'll
have structured the decision in your
mind that's also a spiritual Concept in
in in um in Buddhism it's called in
theera Buddhism it's called Pana which
is a a word from Pali that means you
know the enlightenment um where you go
through the process of trying to make a
decision by thinking or praying about it
in the the the ancient Greeks called it
sunis uh the discernment of spirits in
the ignation Catholic tradition is a a
structured way to make these decisions
and I did you know for 6 months I spent
time on my knees every day man every day
every in in front of the Blessed
Sacrament you know I would pray in front
of the presence of the Lord Lord and
here's what I prayed what do you want
you know guide my path just guide my
path and I felt that the will was um it
the will was that I was supposed to go
someplace to say things that people
didn't expect and where I wasn't
necessarily
invited
so I left my job at the think tank which
is very comfortable and very secure and
I went I went back to Academia but in a
different role as a professor of
practice where the world is the
classroom in a public intellectural role
um I went to Harvard University between
the Harvard Kennedy School which is the
government school and the Business
School
50-50 and uh and I became a columnist at
the Atlantic talking about the science
of happiness and how we can use it how
we can spread the ideas how we can all
be happiness teachers and build a a life
based on Love and Happiness spreading
the ideas of love and happiness back to
the
studs writing for the Atlantic you got a
there's a ton of articles by the way
they're all available you can just
Google them and find them but measuring
your happiness so you can improve it how
to cope with election Agony reading too
much political news is bad for your
well-being why it's so Lonely at the Top
success addicts choose being special
over being happy echo's probably going
to give me a a sideways eye on that one
uh addiction is as addiction does Joo a
college degree is no guarantee of a good
life um so that's what you're writing
about it's every week every week every
Thursday morning in the Atlantic um is
1300 words on the signs of Happiness 52
times a
year I
was intervening with one of my friends
who was having a drinking problem
problem uhhuh and I common common
problem went to his house and this was
at the you know in the midst of an an
intervention that had been ongoing for a
long time right and you know he'd come
clean for a little while and now he's
been missing for a couple days or
whatever you know what's going on go to
his house I'm banging on his door
banging on his door banging on his door
he answers the door of course he's drunk
you know and
um I'm saying Hey listen you you got to
stop like you're you're addicted you're
addicted like this is controlling you
and he looks at me he says well yeah
you're addicted to power he
says you're an addict too yeah I was an
addict too so that's what he it's fair
it's fair you know and you know I we
could go about talk about the
neurophysiology of success addiction
which looks an awful lot like the
neurophysiology of methamphetamine
addiction does it's where you get your
rewards the dopamine patterns in your
brain are habituated to what gives you
the anticipation of great reward and and
you know the the the the dudes listening
to us who drink too much and then quit
are going to be in danger of becoming
addicted to every single other thing in
their lives including the gym including
you know business success and and the
truth is you have to look out for that
you have to look and it's not addicted
personalities it's just brain chemistry
is a way it works out for sure
absolutely and so this is what you're
writing about in all these different
articles you're cover s of Happiness so
it's about 30% Neuroscience which is a
lot of what I teach these days about 50%
social psychology and behavioral
economics and the is how you can apply
these ideas to your life so every week
um I talk about you know what's the
what's the question what's the science
and and not for scientists I mean you
know I'm I I've read 100,000 academic
Journal articles so the readers don't
have to you know I mean this is like I'm
a translator at this point you know I'm
reading all the you know the Deep
science this is how I'm trained and then
I say here's what it means here's
actually you turn it into three lessons
for your life and I'm usually 8 to nine
weeks out in my column and so I'm trying
these things I'm a complete complete
happiness guinea pig I'm trying so my
wife's like what are you doing it's like
ah it's a column you know it's like why
are you trying to learn to walk on your
hands or you know whatever whatever the
thing is but it's cuz I'm trying
something out for my column now it
sounds like you had another hit with the
book uh from strength to strength that
was 2022 and that was a book that I was
working on when I when I retired and I
didn't retire when I when I changed
careers and I came back again to
dedicate my my my work to happiness to
the signs of happiness was the first big
science book on happiness that I wrote
after I came back to Harvard and I guess
it spawns from the title of one of the
articles that you wrote which was your
professional decline is coming much
sooner than you think yeah that's true
which is depressing it's sort of
depressing except that it's it it has a
happy ending to it and here the problem
is that getting into the basic
Neuroscience of of how our careers work
we get we're good at what we do in our
20s and 30s on the basis of something
called f fluid intelligence fluid
intelligence gives you unusual focus it
gives you Creative Energy uh has a ton
of working memory behind it and it
allows you Innovative capacity to do new
things and to solve problems yourself
like a ninja like a cowboy and people
who are super motivated and really
disciplined hard workers they're
listening to your podcast for a reason
that's you dudes in your 20s you're
getting better and better and it's
awesome and the brain power behind that
is called fluid intelligence this was
identified by a social psychologist in
Britain named R name Raymond catel um in
the
1960s and the problem is that it peaks
in your late 30s that fluid intelligence
your working memory your focus your
Innovative capacity your ability to
solve problems by yourself in new ways
that peaks in your late 30s that's the
reason that the average startup Tech
startup with a$1 billion doll valuation
that the the startup founder is 31
that's which is you know it's like it's
it's but you look at at the kinds of
professions that require more standing
knowledge so you know medicine or or law
you find that you know the hottest
litigators are in their late 30s the
most Innovative surgeons are in their
late 30s the best financial
professionals who are doing things in
new ways are in their late 30s musicians
authors electricians air traffic
controllers they their their Peak focus
when they're in their late 30s and then
it starts to decline and and that's why
people start to burn out typically in
their mid-40s they're like I don't know
I you I used to love being a dentist but
now I guess I'm going to start taking
Fridays off I don't know why the reason
is the progress principle once again
they nobody else thinks they're
incompetent they're still really good at
what they do but they're not making
progress anymore and they don't know
that it's because their fluid
intelligence has started to decline so
they can't actually continue to get
better the way they did before that's
why people go into decline you see case
after case after case I talk about it in
the research like um um Charles Darwin
who you know he did his Peak most
Innovative work in his 20s and 30s when
he deved veled the theory of natural
selection AKA Evolution and then you
know after he was about 50 he never made
any more advances you know his his field
passed him by he wrote tons of books but
it wasn't Innovative and he he went to
his grave thinking that he was a
charlatan and a fake because he hadn't
done any new work for decades he hadn't
done any new theoretical work it was all
coming out of you know younger
scientists the reason was because he was
trying to stay on his fluid intelligence
curve and his that curve was in the
cellar man you know I was I was writing
in my in my in my early 30s I was
writing research that was so
mathematically sophisticated I can't
read it today I was doing work on early
artificial intelligence algorithms
called genetic algorithms which are
learning algorithms and I was applying
you know Warf fighting uh simulations
into into this learning algorithm to see
what would work best and let these War
fighting scenarios learn to get better I
was using artificial intelligence
a rudimentary formed and I was writing
papers that was modeling you know
economic uh scenarios and and and
getting these high flutin Publications
that nobody read of course because it's
too Technical and and really boring um
and I can't read it now because that was
my fluid intelligence curve and that's
what a lot of people get stuck on and
they feel disappointed by and then they
wind up the rest of their lives going
yeah and just and and and going for that
next big hit you see entrepreneurs who
have a huge hit in their 30s and in
their 50s they're trying to start a new
thing and and struggling and feeling
frustrated and feeling kind of burned
out and that's because they're on the
wrong curve the good news the happy news
comes after that which is there's a
second intelligence curve that's
different that's increasing in your 30s
and 40s and 50s and it's highest in your
60s and 70s and that's called
crystallized intelligence that's based
on your wisdom and pattern recognition
and your ability to put a whole bunch of
different ideas together that's why
you're a much better
teacher when you're 50 than you were
when you're 30 and even better when
you're 70 the best teaching evaluations
at my University at Harvard go to
professors who are over 70 and it's not
because the students are merciful god
knows it's because they're better Prof
you know like young guys will come out
of men and women will come out of
graduate school and they'll ask you know
what's the secret deg grade teaching
evaluations I'm like get old because you
get on your crystallized intelligence
curve and that your pattern recognition
is high your ability to use metaphor is
really good you're just a much better
teacher you're a better Coach you're a
better Mentor you're a better team
leader you don't want a team leaders 25
the team leaders who are 25 are actually
dangerous because they think like
individuals you want people who are 45
and 55 who who really appreciate the the
unique capabilities of 25y olds and put
them together in their particular
groupings is this making sense to you
giv I me how old are you jao I'm 52
you're 52 you're a young guy yeah but
you're on your fluid you're crystallized
intelligence curve yeah well I was
thinking about my life and so I was like
oh well I didn't really re re uh build
RI myself down to the studs every 10
years CU I was in the Navy for 20 years
then I was like oh no I was enlisted my
first eight years went to college and
then was an officer my last 12 years and
then and then I got out and then I
started doing other things and
definitely you're total spiral I mean as
soon as you told me that because you you
know I knew this about your career
you've told me this before that you were
enlisted and then you did officer
training went to college and then did
command which is a completely different
kettle of fish related same company you
the same organization and then you come
out and you're entrepreneur and being an
entrepreneur in a different way in the
first part of your entrepreneurial life
than the second part of your
entrepreneurial life now you're I mean
you like you even have a podcast Network
why because you're helping other people
to succeed you're finding other authors
and your the imprint that you're doing
because you're helping other you're
you're recognizing talent and helping it
to succeed because you're on your
crystallized intelligence Curve Your
spiral with crystallized intelligence my
fluid intelligence is gone I have no new
idea so I'm like yo can we get some
young guys in here to make some stuff
happen but that's you know it's like
it's no joke it's it's the The Secret of
success and happiness and so you find
the people throughout history who've
been happiest they're the ones who
actually became the the the the graay
Beards they're the ones who actually and
became very comfortable with the idea of
bringing up the next generation of
talent and getting their satisfaction
from that they became the great
instructors Talent recognizers they go
from you know from startup entrepreneurs
to venture
capitalists and we can all do that in
our own way the key thing is what's your
crystallized intelligence curve and then
if you're in your 20s and 30s what do
you think it's going to be and what are
you doing to make it easier to step onto
it when the time comes that's what that
book was about yeah um next up came the
most current book that you wrote which I
have a copy of here today build the life
you want
the Art and Science of getting happier
what was this just an extension of the
Articles initially no what it was it was
the brainchild of my co-author on this
is the first book I've written with
another person in 20 years as a matter
of fact which is pursuing to a very
interesting phone call I got um from
Oprah Winfrey he like the co-author the
co-author Oprah Winfrey calls this is
opra Winfrey and I'm like yeah and I'm
Batman it's opra Winfrey and um she's a
reader of my column and she had read
from strength to strength the book that
we were just talking about uh the first
day it came out I went on her
podcast and her
idea was collaborating on something that
could get the science of Happiness to a
a different audience than I'd ever been
able to touch before into a much bigger
audience because you know Oprah Winfrey
has I mean she's one of the most
respected and iconic figures in American
culture World culture as a matter of
fact and justly so she's amazing um
energetic idealistic helpful full of
love and wants to bring these happiness
ideas because the science of Happiness
she felt had really helped her a lot
during the coronavirus epidemic as she'd
been reading my column and so we spent
you know I we we got together her place
in California and cooked up the
structure of the book and we went away
and and wrote it and passed it back and
forth and it came out September
2023 build a life you
want um it's about emotional
self-management it's about treating your
emotions and understanding your brain as
something under your management as
opposed to managing you that's the
central idea yeah I mean you you kick it
off here you got a a thing you're
talking about Victor Frankle we covered
Victor frankl's um man search for me we
covered that book on like one of the
earlier podcast that we did because
obviously it's such a important powerful
book you saying here frankl's message
was not that life will automatically be
good however which it obviously isn't
nor was it that we can somehow Escape
pain with some special trick he
acknowledges that every life has
suffering some a lot more than others
further as a psychiatrist he knew that
we react to suffering with negative
emotion which is natural but a bad life
is not our fate because we have a choice
as to how we respond to our emotions in
frankl's words everything can be taken
from a man but one thing the last of the
human freedoms to choose one's attitude
in any given set of circumstances to
choose One's Own Way in other words you
can't choose your feelings but you
choose your reaction to your feelings
you could have written that you could
have written that because that's you
know I listen to you and that's what
you're talking about y you can you got
two choices man you can be managed by
your feelings or you can manage your
feelings Choose Wisely choose
appropriately choose in a way that will
be empowering to you and too many people
are going through life hoping for a
better day going through life hoping
that that good feelings will find them
and so okay so Victor Frankl wrote that
and I said let's do and Oprah and I said
said let's let's let's actually explain
the science on how to do that because
the truth is to do that you need to do
three things you need to understand the
science you need to change your habits
and you need to help others in helping
others you imprint these ideas in the
prefrontal cortex of your brain you
experience the ideas where you can
retain them in memory that's why
teaching is so critically important the
reason I teach is because this is you
know not research me search the reason
is because I want to be a happier person
with more love in my life and so I teach
people how to do it and so that's what
we do we talk about how does this work
is a science of what's called
metacognition of understanding and
experiencing your emotions as simple
information there's no bad feelings
there's no such thing as bad feelings or
just information coming from the lyic
system of your brain which is taking the
outside stimuli that's being sensed by
the your brain stem sending it to the
limbic system a console of emotion
producing brain tissue and that
information sending it to the prefrontal
cortex where you decide what it means
and decide what you're going to do
that's how how it works and once you
understand that mechanism and and adopt
a bunch of techniques for doing so it's
like your brain's Under New Management
and there's a there's a new sheriff in
town man and it's the prefrontal cortex
the sea Suite of your brain and that is
a different life experience changed my
life completely yeah you do you have a
good uh the way you explained it here in
the book you say feelings in the
Enterprise of your life are like weather
to a construction company if it rains or
snows or is unreasonably hot it affects
the ability to get work done but the
right response is not trying to change
the weather which would be impossible or
wishing the weather were different which
doesn't help it is having contingency
plans in place for bad weather being
ready and managing projects in a way
that is appropriate to the conditions on
a given day the process of managing this
weather is called metacognition
metacognition metacognition which Tech
technically means thinking about
thinking is the act of experiencing your
emotions consciously separating them
from your behavior and refusing to be be
controlled by them yep that's exactly
right you are not your feelings your
feelings are simply information to give
you to help you understand what's going
on around you in the world the decision
on how to react is yours so I use the
term Detachment to describe what a
person a leader a human being has to do
when things are getting crazy when
there's emotions going on when there's
chaos going on right I've now you know I
talk about how to detach like what the
protocol is to detach match talk to me a
little bit about how you teach people to
practice medic meta metacognition so
your mother when you were a
kid um what did what did your mother
call you when you were a little boy Jo
yeah okay that's good that makes sense
cuz that's your name yep they gave it to
me but what that's that's your nickname
yeah it is a nickname my real name is
John my father's name was also John they
didn't want to have two John's in the
house they gave me the nickname I'm from
I'm from New England they give you weird
nicknames I know that's totally badass I
mean good for your mom well my dad my
dad actually made it up and my dad now
you know he wants a cut yeah totally he
wants a cut he's like oh I could have
named you Biff or whatever you I could
have Nam you Chad or something like yeah
yeah you'd have made that cool too they
could have called you you know you know
puffing boy and that would now that
would be like super cool cuz you made it
as such so um what what what we find is
and what I talk about is the is the fact
that well actually get back to this your
mother probably taught you hey Joo when
you're
angry count it mhm I mean that's that's
classic do you know who made up that
that Axiom count to 10 when you're angry
well it's in your book Thomas Jefferson
yeah Thomas Jeffers and when you're
really angry count 200 yeah and and the
point is get space between your lyic
system and your prefrontal cortex now
your lyic system is a is a console of
tissue it's it's evolved over a 40
million year period its whole job is
emotions and cravings and desires that
sends signals about about what's going
on now where do you want to by the way
those things used to Keep Us Alive oh
totally and you know negative emotions
in particular thank God for your
negative emotions there are four uh
fundamental negative emotions fear anger
disgust and sadness all of them are
evolved for particular reasons I mean
fear and anger come from threat and and
it's fight ORF flight and that actually
stimulates a part of the lyic system
called the amydala which will then
illuminate when something crosses for
the visual cortex in the occipital lobe
of your brain that will send a signal
through your hypothalamus to your
pituitary glands to your adrenal glands
sitting over your kidneys spitting out
stress hormones in 74 milliseconds after
seeing that car barreling toward you in
the crosswalk that of course bypasses
all of your conscious mind and that and
that's when your lyic system with
negative emotions has saved your life
for the thousandth or the 10,000th time
and you in the military more than that
thank God your sadness keeps you
aversive from being from being torn away
from your kin from the people that you
love your disgust keeps you from eating
something that you shouldn't eat because
it might have a pathogen all of these
negative emotions are incredibly
adaptive and super important we should
be really grateful for them we don't
want them to be maladapted or to to
manage us is really what it comes down
to the way that you do that is making
sure that you're understanding those
emotions and your reactions are
occurring not in the lyic system where
they're created but in the in the
prefrontal cortex part of the neocortex
the most evolved part of the human brain
that the wrinkly outside of the brain is
wrinkly because it's a one square meter
piece of tissue that's scrunched up
inside our cranium the most evolved part
of that the most quintessentially human
part of that is the prefrontal cortex a
bumper of tissue right behind your
forehead that's your SE Suite that's
where you're making decisions but it
takes time for the information to get
from your limpic system to your
prefrontal cortex now sometimes you want
to take immediate action like jumping
out of the way of an oncoming car or
doing something that you've taught
yourself instinctively to do like
somebody's firing toward you running
toward the fire and instinctively so
you've retrained your amygdala to do
something that doesn't feel instinctive
but it becomes a new Instinct that's
great but most of the time when you have
aversive reactions when you have
aversive emotions you want to understand
them and make a decision what is the
right thing for me to do I've got this
negative feeling what do I want to do
what's the decision that I'm actually
going to make and that requires time
metacognition is a set of techniques to
put time between what you feel and what
you do and the way that you do is by
understanding yourself is by saying this
is why meditation most for example vas
meditation which is a a very famous
meditative technique of of understanding
yourself you say you know jono's feeling
sad and angry today strange because
things are going pretty well so what's
going on you're talking about yourself
in the third person you're observing
yourself at a certain remove which
sounds sort of weird but but remember
that's what Detachment is you are not
your emotions you're a person that has
emotions so treat them as such with that
kind of remove and that's like counting
to 100 is effectively doing that
journaling your emotions is a very easy
way to move the experience of your
emotions into your prefrontal cortex you
can't write them down from your limic
system directly you can only do that
using your really modern brain uh
prayers of petition are a great way to
do that Lord help me understand why I
feel this way and help me you give me
the grace to to act appropriately what
is your path for me given these things
that I'm feeling this is a perfect
meditate metacognitive technique and and
when you understand that you aren't your
emotions and there are ways that you're
that the SE Suite of your brain can
actually act and and help you to decide
either to put a substitute emotion in
place to get a different reaction to act
as if you had different emotions to
disregard your emotions those are four
you got a repertoire of four things
right there but you can't do it if
you're
reactive yes so I had to learn how to do
this you know being in the military
being in the SEAL Teams there's going to
be times where people are panicking
times where people are freaking out
times where people are angry all these
things and so I had to learn how to do
it then I realized I had to teach other
people how to do it too cuz you can't
have a subordinate leader that is losing
his temper or is flying off the handle
or is panicking and freezing up so I
actually figured out oh I got to teach
these guys to detach some of the things
that I would teach them take a step back
away from the problem like even if it's
in like even if you take a step this
might sound cowardly but if you're in a
gunfight step into a doorway where you
can like take a breath where you're not
worried about dying in the next 3
seconds and you can take a look around
and see what's happening take a breath
this is something that I learned from
being on the radio when you talk on the
radio you don't want to sound like
you're panicked you don't want to sound
like you're freaking out number one cuz
you'll make everyone else panic and
freak out number two because they'll
make fun of you if they're not freaked
out so you don't want either one of
those two things to happen so whenever I
keed up the radio before key the radio
to talk I something going on hey it's
Joo we need to move down the street to
the next building boom and you want a
sound but what that does is and I didn't
realize this at the time but that is
slowing down your breathing your your
your and when you slow down your
breathing it detaches you looking around
just the physical act of looking around
and seeing what else you can see and we
actually do this to a point when you
shoot your weapon when you get done
engaging a Target you train to
mechanically turn your head to the left
turn your head to the right so you can
you you physically scanning and it
forces you to look around right it it
and also widening your view widening
Your Horizon that's like a calming thing
this is why when we go to the ocean we
watch the sunset makes us feel good when
we go to a a mountain and we look at the
broad Mountain it makes us feel good
when we're in a sitting in a cubicle all
day and things are closed in we're
focused we're too focused and it's it
makes us it doesn't make us relax it
does the opposite it makes us anxious
about things that's right so these are
the things to do to step back and make
sure that you're not letting your
emotions make decisions because if we're
making OT emotional decisions we got
problems and you know this is
everybody's listening to us as little
kids your kids are freaking out all the
time you know they they why because
they're incredibly lyic they're lyic
animals and so you say you always yell
at your kids use your words that's just
saying be metacognitive and so in my
house we would say to my kids be
metacognitive it's like oh man what a
drag having a you know social scientist
for a that but and and but people who
are highly reactive are incredibly
unpleasant to be around because they're
Ma they're being managed by their
emotions as opposed to their emotions
managing them all of us can be way way
better at this if we understand that
these things are possible and it just
creates so much power oh it's been
unbelievably lifechanging for me now
it's it's It's tricky because the the
wiring between the lyic system and the
prefrontal cortex is not complete among
adolescents that they have a very
completely wired amydala for example but
an an in completely wired prefrontal
cortex which is why the threats and
opportunities are so acute but they
don't understand they can't make this
metacognitive decisions about risk very
appropriately which is why that they'll
you know the the full wiring of the
brain is not for women is about age 21
for men it's about age 70
so so yeah um so the point is that you
got trying to get me canceled trying to
get me in trouble here I got three
daughters and a wife
I mean so you know this is one of the
reasons that young guys they take stupid
risks a lot is because they're they're
not as they can't they're not as good at
being metacognitive literally because of
the the plasticity or the or the wiring
of the brain is inadequate to it at that
point but you can make it faster and
better um by by teaching people
metacognitive techniques and you can
even do it with little kids and you can
see dramatic results yeah writing things
down and you mentioned it the way I've
described that to people when I say Hey
listen if you're getting emotional
write write down you know as simple as
when your parents would say make pros
and cons right that's a way to detach
from the emotions of the decision that
you've got to make I tell people it
literally detaches you're now 18 in from
the problems you're looking at them you
wrote them down I when uh matter of fact
I I I opened today talking about my
friend Seth who's who died in a
parachute accident and when he died my
he was very close with my whole family
you know he was over for Thanksgiving
and Christmas and all these things cuz
you know his family lived in another
part of the country and he's you know
he's in the SEAL Teams and so he's
growing my kids are growing up around
him and when he died my son who was very
close with him cuz you know we all
surfed we all play guitar we're all
hanging out all the time almost like a
bunch of uh kids you basically and but
my son was very close with him so when
when Seth died maybe a couple months ago
by and he was I think about 14 been he's
in high school and after a few months
came home and and you know my son's not
a very you know he not a very like
highly emotional person or anything just
a normal kid right and more important
like a normal boy so there's not a lot
of like emotional things going on it's
like oh what's the problem no problem
we'll carry on you know just kind of
that attitude but one day he came home
to me and said like I when I'm in school
I keep thinking about Seth and I I'm I'm
feeling sad about it and I can't really
concentrate right and what I had learned
and this kind of crystallized this
thought for me was that when my friends
had died including Seth what did I when
I lost guys in combat what did I have to
do I had to go and write a eulogy I knew
I was I know when one of my friends dies
I start writing because I got to write I
know I'm going to be talking in 3 days
at the
memorial so that became what I've what I
had done and what I realized was when
you write it helps you process those
emotions so I told my son hey I want you
to write a letter to Seth and tell him
what you thought what you thought of him
the good times you had what you're going
to miss and sure enough he did
it and he never asked me about him again
yeah yeah this is a classic case and you
know this uh lists are is journaling is
so powerful because of this because of
the metacognitive effect that it
actually has on the brain and so another
example of this is you know a lot of
people there's an explosion of so-called
generalized anxiety in our in our
society today especially among young
adults and so they'll go to therapy and
they'll say you have anxiety as if it
were some sort of a switch which is not
it's a it's a dial every single person
listening to us is anxious the question
is how high is the dial turned and how
disruptive is it for their lives is what
it comes down to anxiety is unfocused
fear now fear is an amydala response to
to threat and the way that that that our
bi our biology is evolved is for fear to
be intense and episodic that's how fear
is supposed to work you're on the in the
place to scene you're living on the
Savannah you hear a twig snap behind you
your amydala illuminates you take off
running you don't think oh um that must
be one of my friends behind me no you're
like that's probably bad or it might be
bad and you don't stop to think and you
run you climb a tree and that's your
amydala saving your life that's the fear
respons episodic and intense the problem
is in Modern Life it's constant and
vague and so and that's gives you a
little drip of cortisol into your brain
all the time all the time all the time
so that unfocused fear is generalized
anxiety and the way that you deal with
this most appropriately is by focusing
it is focusing your fear and the best
way to do that is when your chest is
tight and You' got butterflies in your
stomach and you don't know why you say
all right I'm I'm kind of freaking out a
little bit little here so I take out a
piece of paper number one what's what am
I afraid of right now like like come on
put it down here what am I worried about
I'm worried about something I'm I'm I'm
afraid of something right now write it
down what is it why do I feel this way
what's the worst thing that can happen
and what am I going to do if it happens
happens now let's go on to number two by
the time you get to number five you're
like I can analyz why because you've
focused your unfocused fear and you've
taken generalized anxiety and you've
you've organized it around the way fear
is supposed to feel which is a normal
part of a normal life MH and it's a
positive thing when it's the right thank
God in the right mode thank God for fear
you'd be dead you wouldn't make it past
your second
birthday I'm going to fast forward and
by the way uh much of what you're saying
is in the book get go get the book we
don't have time to to read the whole
thing but uh fast forward to hear a
little bit a section that's about Focus
Less on yourself and you've got this
really interesting I don't know if I
want to call it an experiment but they
they take these three groups of people
uh 263 participants and they group them
into different three three different
groups with different set of
instructions the first group is called
the moral Deeds group and they're
instructed today you have to go and do
at least one moral deed for someone else
go out and help somebody else random
back to kindness the next one is the
moral thoughts group and what they're
directed to do is go out and have at
least one moral thought for other people
and then the last group is the treat
yourself group and it's today do at
least one positive thing for yourself so
these are the three groups the Fe and
you go into some detail about it but the
the I'll I'll fast forward a little bit
here the moral Deeds group reported
higher scores on a range of well-being
meas me than the moral thoughts group
and both reported higher scores than the
treatyourself group right those caring
for others actively felt greater purpose
in life and sense of control While
others did not they were also the only
ones who felt less anger and social
isolation yeah that's you may want to
pay attention to that people yeah yeah
yeah this is the thing this is if you
don't know if you're feeling bad and you
don't know what to do help somebody if
you're if you don't know what to do and
you're feeling crummy go help somebody
go do something I'm so happy to hear you
say that I have people you know say oh I
can't I don't really know what I should
be focused on I can't find a purpose and
I'm like oh you you don't can't figure
out what to do co go help someone else
go down to a soup kitchen and start
helping other people yeah yeah or or
what the the advice a lot of young
people get to get today is if you're
feeling really crummy self-care you need
some self selfcare I've even heard
radical self-care I mean what the heck
is radical self-care the whole point is
other care man is what it comes down to
if you're feeling lousy if you're
feeling lonely if you're feeling
rejected if you're feeling blue go do
something for somebody and and by the
way there's so much that you can do
there's so much around us you know we're
in Southern California right now which
is I mean there's so much homelessness
around us what can you do I was actually
talking to a group of of of Christian
college students and they're like so so
what does it mean to love my neighbor
what what do I do for one of the
homeless people and you know there's a
lot of controversy about that should I
give them money not give them money
probably not because there's so much
substance abuse and and give them a
sandwich sure absolutely but but then go
one step further you want to you want to
you want to make it radical H say to the
guy would you pray for me and my
family why because you just gave them
dignity because you said I need you I
need you why I mean look Christian
people we believe that God hears the the
cries of the poor ESP
God hears the cries of the poor so he
needs a sandwich great you need his
prayers to get you into heaven that's
what you need so ask him for him I mean
your life's going to change you're going
to help him because you gave him the
dignity but your life is actually going
to change your day is going to change
your outlook is going to change you
ready for that you ready ready to be a
radical or you can or you can go get a
massage go get cucumbers in your
eyes
um you talk about these pillars um you
say you can find thousands of dubious
happiness hacks on the internet to adopt
for a monthly subscription fee of course
we're getting some one weird trick don't
eat grapes I don't know you
know uh you talk about the social
science research and you get to these
four pillars the four pillars are family
friendship work and Faith yeah family
these are people we are given in our
lives and generally don't choose except
for our spouse friendship this is the
bond with people we love deeply but who
aren't kin work this is our toil to earn
our daily bread to create value in our
lives and the lives of others it might
be paid or unpaid in the marketplace or
at home and Faith this does not mean a
specific religion but rather is a
shorthand term for having Transcendent
View and approach to life yeah these are
the four I mean it's there's there's
10,000 habits of the happiest people but
they're all trivial you know should you
eat asparagus or broccoli should you do
MMA or resistance training at on On Any
Given Wednesday I mean it's great but
and it's interesting but the truth of
the matter is that there's a portfolio
of things that we need to invest invest
in every day sort of the happiness 401k
plan every day pay attention to your
faith every day pay attention to your
spiritual walk the sense of transcendent
making yourself small getting out of
your own personal Psycho Drama zooming
out right second is your family life and
you know family are these mystical
relationships I mean we could talk about
that
the neurophysiology of oxytocin which is
a neuropeptide that bonds us to each
other we sort of mentioned that a little
bit earlier and that's especially acute
especially intense in the case of family
relationships but it's magic man you
remember when your first baby was born
and you made eye contact with your first
baby and you would literally die for
that baby in one second and that was
it's like the Fourth of July inside your
head and it's weird because you know you
didn't know that baby that baby didn't
know you and and yet and that's magic
and and people are walking away from
those relationship ships because of
idiocies like politics it's so insane
getting conscripted into some baby
boomer politicians culture War it's just
nuts and then friendship you know
friendship is a crisis in America huge
crisis it's one of the great climate
changes and happiness is the fact that
that technology has made it harder and
harder for us to have in-person
relationships uh and real friendships
not deal friendships and not virtual
friendships deal friendships people can
help you professionally virtual
friendships people you don't see and
touch those aren't good enough you need
real friendships they're good and
useless is what it comes down to and
last but not least you got to do two
things with your work you got to earn
your success the old-fashioned way
through hard work personal Merit and
responsibility and you got to serve
others and if you do those things your
life's going to change but you got to
not be distracted and you have to pay
attention you have to do it on purpose
and so that's actually worth a strategic
plan for the rest of your life is faith
family friends and work and I mean I
have those are the those are the
strategies that actually get you to the
basic macronutrients the protein
carbohydrates and fat of Happiness are
really enjoyment and satisfaction and
purpose those are the three
macronutrients of happiness and the way
that you feed yourself those things are
are with faith family friends and work
that we're talking about here and you
need a strategy for that I have a I have
a very complex strategy that I have put
together with a spreadsheet where I take
my my macronutrients enjoyment
satisfaction and purpose and I have the
micronutrients that scale up into those
macronutrients and every month I'm
looking at them and every half year
every my birthday and half birthday I'm
I'm putting together a strategy to make
sure that it's on point I'm making
progress that's how important that stuff
is and and you know I'm 60% happier than
I was 5 years ago so works for me and
and I've seen it actually work for my
students as
well the Chunk on family you got a whole
Chunk on family in the book it's uh it's
called build your imperfect family so I
think everyone that's doesn't need any
explanation you talk about conflict
acknowledging family conflict is good
yeah improves communication like this is
just that acknowledgement like when you
have an argument with somebody or
disagreement with somebody it's okay
totally as long as you don't get
emotional about it and fly off the
handle if you don't then you don't love
enough you know I'm married to a
Spaniard so it's like 10,000 fights you
know for Spanish people it's just the
it's a it's a kind of communication is
you know angrily yelling but the but you
know different to a Brit and there's
like no stiff upper lip we don't we
don't have arguments even it's just like
so chill wow you know what's that like I
wonder awesome I mean yeah yeah she you
know we we just don't I mean first of
all I don't get emotional about things I
don't get mad about really anything you
know like no matter what my wife does
doesn't really make me mad and my wife
when she gets mad which I do things that
will make her mad it lasts about 8 to 12
minutes right she'll clean aggressively
during those 8 to 12 minutes that's what
that's what her thing is she'll
aggressively clean and that's how you
know yeah and that's how I know and then
and then she's then she realizes that
you know I'm probably just I'm just dumb
or you know I do dumb things at a
minimum and she forgives me and we move
on just Joo being Joo that's great you
know and we all have how long youve been
married
um as I tell my wife she's going to be
cleaning aggressively tonight when Shear
as I she's already hear me say I always
say the same thing when somebody ask me
that question I go I don't know what it
seems like forever but my wife is like
10es underw 8 years or something like
that 28 years 20 something like that
yeah 27 years I've married 32 it's it's
it's you know and and she's the last
person you lay your eyes on as you take
your dying breath my wife uhhuh oh yeah
I'm sure she will be that's beautiful
she might be barking orders at me or
something no she'll be cleaning
aggressively she'll be why are you
leaving uh you talk about this
complimentary relationship thing and and
how now you know you go through this and
again get the book it's all in there but
you know this idea that oh you got to
find someone that's like you right to be
to have a happy marriage when in fact
the I wouldn't say the exact opposite
but certainly a little bit of the
opposite is true this is a huge problem
in modern dating because it it's
interesting because I've looked at the
data as you can imagine um when I'm
teaching this class at at HBS called
leadership and happiness this is the
unit they're most in they're most
interested in is romantic relationships
and the
neurobiology and psychology of romantic
relationships so I talked to him about
the neurochemical Cascade of falling in
love what's actually happening
hormonally in your brain what's the
point after which you can't control it
anymore so you know when you have a case
study of a CEO gets fired for for having
a a romantic relationship with a
subordinate and they're always saying at
the end I don't know what happened but
what happened is you there's a certain
point Beyond which you can't let it go
and this is the reason you should not be
ping around with people with whom you
could conceivably have a romantic
relationship at work that's the reason
that you have to you know guard your
affections and guard your heart that's
the reason that you shouldn't be staring
into each other's eyes for three minutes
because you're going to be releasing a
ton of neuromodulators into your brain
that's going to start to capture your
brain it's going to start to to to
hijack the control of your brain on the
basis of this neurochemical Cascade and
I walk them through all that how the
science Works they're like holy mackerel
I can also talk to them about how you
can fall in love with almost anybody who
would be appropriate to you to your you
know your your your um your sexual
orientation and your age and whether or
not you're single etc etc but and you
can through a series of steps actually
initiate that Cascade but then I talk
about the mistakes that people ini on
the other person yeah yeah exactly
exactly so there's a lot of research
that shows for example that I mean
there's this one famous experiment by a
guy who teaches a psychologist at Sunni
uh Stony Brook guy named art Aaron great
psychologist and he did a he did a a
piece of research in which he did an
experiment in which people who were
complete strangers but who were
theoretically capable of falling in love
um college students they would come into
a room they'd met each other for the
first time they started by asking each
other a series of 36 questions of
escalating intimacy so the first is
something dumb like if you could have
dinner with anybody who would it be and
and by the 30th question of 36 is when's
the last time you cried and why you know
right and so it's like what's your tell
me about your relationship with your
mother you know this kind of thing and
and then at the end then they have to
stare into each other's eyes for four
minutes which is just initiating this
neurobiological explosion in their
brains because that is actually how we
release oxytocin and so you're bonding
with the other person this love
molecules endogenously on a pump and and
people walked down and one after the
other said I feel like I just fell in
love I am I that person knows more about
me than than my girlfriend of 6 months
or two years and and one of the couples
in that original experiment got married
I mean not the day not the same day but
you know they started going out and and
so I I talked to them about actually how
this works and how it can be used for
good and how it can be used for bad and
how it can ruin your life and how it can
wreck your career and then I talked to
him about the mistakes that they're
making because they're not initiating
these things in their dating lives you
know if they're on the apps dating you
find that people have way more uh Choice
a lot more variety than they've ever had
before of potential mates and they like
and are attracted less
and are less successful in dating than
ever before why is that it's a real it's
perplexing but it turns out it's
scientifically very straightforward the
reason is because they're selecting
people on the basis of similar
characteristics that they're curating in
their dating profiles so when you put
together your dating profile we're all
such narcissists it's like it's like who
do I want I want like if I were dating
right now it's like I want to I don't
know I what do I want I want to date
Arthur Brooks it's like you might as
well that is so not hot and and so what
what what people do is that they they're
they describe somebody they want to date
who's more or less like their sibling
and and so that's one of the reasons
that they they get people who are a good
match for them as a friend but not a
good match for them as a mate what you
need is a baseline of compatibility same
religion that's fine same region of the
country that's fine but then you need
complimentarity that's why matchmakers
are so good matchmakers will find
somebody who's the same enough very low
level and then really different there's
tons of research that actually shows
that when people are really different
than us that we sense the
neurobiological difference or the
biological differences than us because
that gives us a sense of the
immunological differences so that when
we have kids the kids have a more
diverse immunological profile and
they're more likely to survive so for
example there's one experiment for the
90s that's really great that's been
replicated a bunch of times so it's
legit where these these college students
these women they're given shoe boxes
with t-shirts in them the t-shirts have
been worn born for 48 straight hours by
different guys that they don't know and
they have to smell there holes in the
shoe box they have to smell the shoe box
and to say how attractive the guy is
just on the basis of the smell then they
match up how immunologically different
the guy who was wearing the t-shirt is
from the woman and compare it to how hot
she thought he was on the basis of the
smell of his sweat turns out the more
different he is the more you like him
because the old factory bulb in your
brain is ascertaining that he is
physiologically more different than you
and so your kids are going to be
healthier so this all translates into
find different people date people from
different cultures and different
backgrounds and different countries and
different races and go wild man I mean
it's like Embrace diversity
literally check uh another thing you got
in this family section is the negativity
virus you say the ambient culture in a
family or any close-nit group determines
the ability of the members to solve
problems think of it as like a room
temperature if the room temperature in
your house is 100° and you're feeling
too hot it doesn't really matter how
many clothes you take off you still be
too hot similarly negative culture in a
family can take can make problem solving
impossible so there's no growing growth
or learning just chronic unhappiness
this often occurs because of emotional
contagion which psychologists have
studied extensively there's not a
particular problem to solve just uh this
sucks attitude that moves between family
members yeah or between community
members or between you when I go into
companies is the first thing I look for
is emotional negative emotional
contagion and what I try to do is to
help leaders inject the positive
emotional virus into the company this
must be true in the military as well
this is when I read that that's the same
thing I thought I there was platoon you
could see the platoon you'd watch the
platoon for three minutes and you go oh
this is going to be a problem I walk
into a company I've walked into
companies where it you feel the horror
of the negativity that's going on inside
that company and you got to get a grip
on that really quick and get it changed
around for sure this is the problem in
Academia today it's an emotional virus
an Academia of sadness and anger sadness
and anger what what what what's rewarded
sadness and anger is rewarded in a lot
of Academia and that's a huge problem
for the the well-being of the students
and faculty you know that's and so and
that requires leadership that's going to
inject a better virus is what it comes
down to so you got to get it under
control you have to acknowledge the fact
that the the place is sick you have to
say this is not what we want we're not
going to create a culture where this is
encouraged and then you have to have a
leader who has leaders under her or
himself who are propagating a better
virus
MH
um forgiveness yeah huge part of things
huge part of the world huge part of the
failure of of people and cultures and
countries um you talk about
forgiveness and you have some different
strategies um there's discussion let's
talk through this so I can let go of the
hurt explicit forgiveness I forgive you
non-verbal forgiveness such as showing
affection after a fight and minimization
which involves classifying the
transgression as unimportant and simply
choosing to disregard it all four of
these strategies can be effective
depends on the severity of the grievance
right but the whole point is forgive
more forgive more that's the secret to
staying married is forgiving that's the
secret because she going to bum you out
and you're going to bum her out and you
have to have a policy of forgiveness an
explicit policy of forgiveness and so
you you don't necessarily need to say
when she's really mad at you look honey
I forgive you because that's going to
make her angrier because you know she
she feels like she's the one who's
grieved and that's typically how
conflict works but the whole point is
you got to say basically you know by the
end of the day I'm going I'm forgive man
it's just that's what we do it's How We
Roll we forgive we forgive our kids we
forgive our loved ones and forgive over
and over and over again now not
forgiving is basically like holding on
to a hot coal right and and hoping it
burns the other person that's it's not
going to work and it's an incredibly
self-defeating strategy is is the way
that this turns out and a lot of people
will hold on to it because they actually
want to be fired up by it they want to
get the energy that actually comes from
the anger and the hostility and the
hatred toward other and it's it's uh
it's one of the best ways to become
ineffective personally and and it's it's
a it's a true and tried and true way to
become as unhappy as possible yeah and
then you talk again in the book about
conditional forgiveness and pseudo
forgiveness classic conditional
forgiveness is I'll forgive you when you
do X and Y and pseudo forgiveness is
like just not true yeah that's right I'm
going to act this if I forgive you but
I'm not and I'm going to hold it over
your head and I'm going to bring it up
every you know it's like remember when
you did that thing it's like I thought
you forgave me for that yeah I did but
now we're bringing it up
again um another challenge in the family
situation dishonesty yeah and you say
here in the 1990s the writer and
psychotherapist Brad Blandon argued just
that in his book radical honesty when
the truth is hard to accept telling it
can have
costs including Frid relationships at
home but Blandon suggested that complete
honesty no white lies no exception
is worth the consequences because it can
reduce stress deepen connections with
others and reduce emotional reactivity
yeah this is actually uh a strategy that
a lot of young people who are listening
to us could adopt to great effect is to
say you know I'm I'm going to stop lying
and it's so so many people's lives are
revolving around a series of shadings of
the truth and the way that they talk
about themselves to protect themselves
or whatever it happens to be and say I'm
I'm not going to lie anymore I'm not
going to lie about anything I'm not
going to lie about how many beers I
drank I'm not going to lie about how
many people I dated I'm not going to lie
about how long I've been looking for a
job and I've been off the market I'm
going to take every single shading of
the truth out of my out of my resume I'm
going to talk to people in an honest way
when I don't like something I'm going to
say it when I actually do like somebody
and this is the really scary thing for a
lot of young people when I like somebody
I'm going to tell them right it's like
man I find you so attractive and saying
just that kind of radical honesty which
opens you up to all sort exposes you it
exposes you and but then you become so
much tougher and and you've got nothing
to hide anymore it can be truly a
life-changing thing this is the one
truth is the one intervention that can
actually make more difference in the
lives of a lot of young people that
don't feel like their life is on track
than almost anything else it's kind of
like the it's almost like the Magic
Bullet there is not one hack because
life is all about habits but you know
how that you know you know what was it
Admiral
what was it mcraven who yeah who said
you know make your bed y right okay fine
but what that is is is is is have
integrity even when it doesn't really
matter have integrity and in so doing
you put your life in order to stop lying
that's real I mean that is uh that and
and man you wake up every day and say
today's another day I'm not going to lie
and sometimes it's going to be good and
sometimes it's going to be bad but it's
going to be
interesting when I think through I've
had quite a few disc question about this
over the years and because this is a
huge component of moving forward in life
right is telling the truth and so we get
into these discussions where well you
know if my wife
makes chicken for dinner in fact this is
the first time we talked about it on the
podcast it was years and years ago my
wife used to cook very dry chicken uh
cook it for an hour this now has been
completely soft because she got received
thousands of recipes and cooking
instructions on how to cook chicken and
keep it moist so now she cooks the best
chicken in the world but she used to
cook dry chicken and you know you think
through okay when she says how's the
chicken you know she spent probably two
hours making it cuz 5 minutes of prepa
then she had to cook it for an hour and
minutes to get all the liquid and fluid
out of it but it took her two hours to
make this thing right so I come home
she's been working she went out and got
the stuff she got it ready she's
watching three kids four kids whatever
and she you know she puts the chicken in
front of me and says how's the
chicken and
the common theory is well you tell her
the truth right hey this dry can you get
me a gallon of water please over here to
wash this thing down what's that going
to get me where's that going to take me
but yes I should tell the truth but and
here's where I I I had a little bit of
Enlightenment in the way that I lived my
life for me being very hardcore with the
truth I make sure that I aim that at my
myself first mhm
so when my wife asks me how's the
chicken the first thing I should ask
myself
is
well how important is this to me as a
person right now like what's the truth
about this chicken what what is the
truth about this chicken the truth about
this chicken is my wife spent all day
making it my wife did all these things
my wife put care and effort into this
chicken and that's freaking amazing you
know how this chicken is it's awesome
this chicken is awesome because and this
is the same with you know if you if you
work for me and you know I you're not
doing what you're supposed to be you're
you got your project turned in late
right okay radical honesty I go up to
you and say hey you know Arthur you
turned in this project late I'm going to
write you up if this happens again okay
that's one way of doing it but actually
if I aim that at myself first and I say
Hey Arthur I noticed that you got your
project turned in late I don't think I
gave you the support that you needed I
don't think I gave you the resources and
I actually was revie viewing our email
chain and I didn't really clarify the
actual timeline in a specific way so I
made it clear enough so you could
understand next time those are the
things I'm going to change so that this
project will get done or the next
project will get done on time so that's
me being radically honest with myself
and the things that I can change the
things that I can do better and I think
that's the point to start at yeah yeah
no being honest with yourself is the
beginning of radical honesty being
honest with others is derivative and and
the pre that we like to lie to the most
are are ourselves we love to lie to
ourselves we lie to ourselves constantly
and then we'll like oh I'll be I'll be
honest with you but and this is a very
good point it's also the framing of what
we're talking about the truth of the
matter is that she's not asking you how
is the chicken she's asking you how do
you feel about her taking care of you
and you feel really good about that and
you can say yeah and the chicken is one
tiny part of it that the temperature and
the dryness of the chicken is one is
1% of the answer to this particular
question so let's answer the 99% which
really matters and and it's it's
critical because we can do that in
almost everything that we do and that's
the way that we can use the truth as a
gift and not as a weapon and you can
also answer that question with a
question which is can you please pass
the catchup yeah that's right can
you uh as you go through the book look
you go through the details of friendship
of of work um you know what what you
detail these things and in in how we can
move these things forward and you know
you end up with really nice kind of
pragmatic synopsises of each of these
you know you say Blissful work of
friendship friendship is incorrectly
seen by many people as something that
just occurs naturally without conscious
effort or work this is false like
everything else important friendship
requires attention and work it must be
built on purpose and you go through the
the
protocol the protocol friendship is
ruined when you look for people who are
useful uh too many deep friendships
today are spoiled by differences of
opinion isn't this the truth right now
yeah for sure uh the goal for long-term
romance is a special kind of friendship
not undying passion so you go through
these things and you give really really
pragmatic advice this isn't like a book
that's not a theory book just about
Theory anybody wants to read the
underlying science which is
approximately zero% of the readers um
it's all in the it's all in the end
notes to the book you know you'll get
the actual academic citations what we're
talking about if you want to read the
Neuroscience literature great more power
to you anybody who wants to come study
with me and do their PHD under me at
Harvard that's great read the read the
endnotes and you know we'll write some
articles together that but but for the
rest of humanity that just wants to live
a better life in a in an evidence-based
science-based way that that's Oprah and
I wrote the book for you um and I'll
close out the book with this again get
the book there's so much information in
here um you talk about you already
mentioned this but become a teacher
right yeah and you say the reason is
pretty simple you already know it you
need to be metacognitive with the
information to use your prefrontal
cortex so you can understand and use it
the best way to do that is to be able to
explain it clearly this is what I I
learned that I was lucky enough in my
career I told you before we started that
I had a very lucky career one of the
things that was so lucky is when I was
an enlisted
guy my last couple years as an enlisted
guy I worked in the training cell at
Seal Team 1 where I taught land Warfare
combat swimmer Close Quarters combat
Urban combat I taught those things and
when you teach you learn magic yeah by
the time I was by the time I was now in
an off in in a leadership role I had
learned well where I had crystallized
information really at a pretty young age
yeah yeah for sure and it made it made
you're much better what you do right now
because of that training and and the
development of your crystallized
intelligence before that was your
strength which is so great you were able
to walk from one curve to the other
you're probably much happier than I mean
you had a glorious really great career
in the military you're probably happier
now is my guess because you're living
your right curve you're living your
correct curve right I would say that
I've I'm I'm always pretty happy and I
was very happy when I was in the
military the the entire time it's funny
you know I look back I was a new guy in
a seal platoon I was so happy I was on a
in an ARG platoon on a ship in 115
degree birthing space yeah I've heard
about I've heard about that from my son
how fun that is I was happy for 3 weeks
I was happy we were happy you know like
that's and then became an officer in a
leadership position all the pressure
happy that's great just happy and then
uh retired found other missions to
execute on still happy still getting
after it yeah it's great and but a lot
of people listening to us they don't
that's hard to relate to because they
find that they're they're more
melancholic they find that happiness
comes a little harder to them the truth
is that we all have different
different aptitude udes for it we all
have different characters for it we all
have the same emotions but we have
different intensities of emotions so one
of the things that we talk about in the
book and I do a lot with my work is I
can actually I can give people a
personality test on the intensity of
their positive and negative emotions
you're clearly a very high positive
affect person you're probably a
relatively moderate low affect person uh
um negative affect person so you're you
you would fit the cheerleader profile a
lot you know um I fit going to enjoy
that one and well I mean it's like yeah
especially because you're there with the
pom poms in a little skirt right now
it's really it really becomes you ja um
I'm the mad scientist which means I have
very high positive and very high
negative effect and this is normal about
a quarter of the population has this um
a quar of the population has high
positive low negative effect naturally
this is the poetic effect effect it has
to do with a part of the limbic system
called the the ventrolateral prefrontal
cortex which is the part of the brain
that's hyperdeveloped that's unusually
big for people who are are able to
ruminate on certain things which gives
them a melancholic nature it also tends
to make them very creative because you
ruminate on a business plan or an opera
or a book of poetry makes them very
romantic because you ruminate on another
person that's called infatuation and
those are beautiful things but you have
to learn to you have to learn to manage
that affect and there are people who are
very low affect people low positive and
low negative it's not they're not
unhappy or happy they just have low
expression of their positive and
negative emotions and every every one of
us is in one of these quadrants and and
all of it's a gift no matter what it is
you just have to know what it means and
how to use it how to surround yourself
with people who can help you who can
complete you and learn how to manage it
in a way that's that builds you up and
helps other people as well so they some
people will listen to you and say like
like jacko's happy doing all these
really aversive and hard things you know
why can't I be like that well because
God Made You Different is the whole
point but that doesn't mean that you
can't manage yourself that doesn't mean
that you can't make yourself better you
can't use your natural predilections for
for the good of yourself and good of
other people God wanted poets too you
know and and a whole world of
cheerleaders would be problematic
actually you know we want all the
different kinds of people that we have
and we and we need all different kinds
of people that we have but all of us can
be much better than we were
yeah um well that's the latest book um
what does that get us up to speed for
right now yeah it came out in September
2023 and we're talking about that about
you know two months after the book came
out it's been a wild ride being on tour
with Oprah Winfrey has been quite
something there's a lot of security okay
yeah a lot more security than you know
people are like Arthur Who but you know
yeah no it's great and it's it's uh it's
been a joy I'm actually starting the
next book which will come out probably
in Spring of 2025 called start strong
which is the science that people need to
start their adult lives in their 20s in
a way that will give them the absolute
best trajectory for Success love and
happiness going forward science-based
approach on how to how to build your
life starting good young and when's that
one coming out in the spring of 2025
okay meantime we're doing a lot of lot
of a lot of media projects op and I we
did a we started a we did a a limited
run podcast together um based on the
book um and what's that called that's
that's part of her Super Soul series on
on that it's called build the life you
want so if you look on YouTube there's a
series of conversations that we did at
her place in in Santa Barbara and uh and
who knows you know we we're talking to
you know different television and you
know video outfits on what we can do
next but the whole point is that people
want to be happier and it sure is great
to be on The Cutting Edge of that
business yeah it is it beats working and
people can find you you got Arthur
brooks.com yeah you've got you're on
Twitter yeah Arthur Brooks you're on
Instagram Arthur C Brooks you got a
YouTube channel got a YouTube channel
Arthur brooks1 123 yeah did you know
that really it's Arthur brooks1 123
that's good to know and then you're on
Facebook Arthur Brooks yeah and and
you're giving up giving particular ideas
the one thing I'm not doing is you know
diet and exercise but you that's why I'm
going to other other people I I do work
I've done some stuff with Peter AA
lately and you know good good guys like
that because that's uh I'm I'm an
Enthusiast but I'm an amateur awesome um
Echo Charles you got any questions yeah
got a few limited but I got a few on
this one okay so uh as far as um
friendships go right in person better so
what about uh exchanging memes is that
conducive to Friendship it is and part
of the reason is because humor is a
great source of bonding and so as long
as they're not bitter as long as they're
not denigrating as as long as they're
not tearing other people down that's
important bonding over stuff that's
actually legitimately I know whatever we
just got rid of all your memes but
anyway that if you're doing something
that's genuinely funny you know humor is
the is the the universal language um of
friendship you know it's and it's an
amazing thing because we actually
understand the neurophysiology of how
how humor works yeah and it's just a
beautiful thing it just lights up your
brain so let me ask you this then okay
so I have a twin brother yeah he
identical or fraternal wow so we we grew
up like I think a lot of guys and even
military like this you know when you
play team sports like this where part of
the humor and part of the fun and the
bonding is insulting each other you know
but I always um I always had it in my
head where the the better insults are
the ones that are more funny than
insulting kind of a thing and the more
clever I guess you know so it's like
this match back and forth where it's
like you know and when you take offence
you kind of automatically lose you know
kind of a thing what's with that like
why do people Bond on that whatever BR
you the same way just as charge the the
the closest relationships are ones where
we can we can recognize the foibles and
weaknesses of a friend and then and make
it into a source of of laughter as oppos
as opposed to a source of actual ual
derision or contempt this is the same
this is the thing because you know look
we all have weaknesses and when you see
the weakness in somebody else and treat
it with affection Right generally
speaking the way that the guys will
treat will they'll Express that
affection as with humor and if it's
understood as such look there there a
fine line and so when you're making fun
of your buddy because of you know
whatever he's got you know his premature
balding or whatever it happens to Beck
if it's a if it's a source of affection
you're going to talk about it in one way
if it's a source of contempt or actual
insult you're going to treat in a
different way and that line is really
fine between them and when you've
actually gone from making them laugh to
making them unhappy that's when you know
you've crossed that line a little bit so
it's and and it can be pretty subtle it
can be pretty subtle believe me as a guy
I'm like a bald guy you know we're we're
we're
sensitive understood completely and then
um also the oxytocin in the workplace
scenario you're talking about so let's
say my wife hypothetically has a
coworker you know co-ed cooworker
that she's close to nowadays you know
kind of a thing talking hypothetically
but I'm my wife's coworker currently so
just yeah that's good that's right but
is that a red flag it well depends and
so one of the things one of the big
mistakes that people make in companies
is number one saying that you actually
can't start romance in the workplace I
mean I understand the liability that
comes along with that but about 17% of
people meet their spouse at work the
problem is when people who are not
available meet each other at work and
have an illicit relationship when the
real problems come and usually those are
pursuant to them doing a lot of stuff
outside of work and that mean at work
but they're having personal
conversations and a lot of one-on-one
time and a lot of deep conversations a
lot of the revelation of personal traits
and what's going on with their home
relationships and a lot of deep looking
in the eye which will actually instigate
oxytocin release then the second thing
that workplaces will do that actually
relate that winds up creating chaos in
the relationships of their of their
employees is a lot of offsite activities
for team building so if you're going
canoeing with somebody who could
technically be your romantic partner but
you're you already have a partner and
you're the canoeing with somebody the
outside fraternizing activity with
somebody will stimulate a lot of the
feelings that you'll get because you'll
associate fun and oxytocin with a person
who's not your spouse and that's
dangerous interesting you got to protect
yourself you got to take measures you
got to guard your heart and and if
you're a boss you should be helping and
not making it harder for people to guard
their hearts so if you're a husband at
home uh your wife's going out on
canoeing team building scenarios with
their co-workers it's not necessarily
like you know the husband might get
accused of being this jealous husband
you know they're just friends and all
this other stuff but and it might be
true it might be just friends you know
and you have to trust the Integrity of
your partner you want to have a partner
who has real Integrity but the whole
point is that if they're just they
they're they really really really love
those activities that I mean that's it's
just you know people are different but
there's risk that comes from this
there's just natural risk that comes
from this so the husband kind of has a
leg to stand on some of the time yeah
and yeah I mean it's I that yeah the
biology suggests that that is that there
is risk involved now how do you react to
that in a mature way that's a different
kettle of fish kettle of fish it's true
but it's not nothing bro it's not
nothing but I'm telling you br you get a
a pretty girl at work with a husband and
some single guys at work as well or
whatever but you think the single guys
have respect for the all the oxytocin or
lack thereof at home and all this stuff
they don't so I'm just saying yeah it's
work is a funny thing because people
spend so much time there most people
spend more time at work than they spend
with their spouse yeah and when you're
spending time with somebody in a very
tight-knit work team and especially
having intimate conversations that are
not work related and especially doing
things where they're sharing fun
activities and and it's more time than
you're actually spending with your
spouse I mean you're you know you're
opening up yourself to feelings that you
probably didn't anticipate yeah uh last
question so when we're in a chamber
French horn scenario chamber music
French who are we playing for like what
not at the nightclub or nothing like
that no it's not night it's usually
audiences and so what people they the
chamber music concert series where where
people subscribe and they come and they
hear that that they'll they'll book four
or five different groups over the course
of the year and then they they'll come
and it'll be like a Sunday out yeah and
then the touring group comes through oh
that's cool like where would it be at
like a um like a concert Civic Center
concert hall so like a jazz band
compared speak yeah thek Rock I guess
right so be okay so there's like an
audience yeah exity that likes that's
super into it yeah yeah so it's again
you know Rising that in that hierarchy
is pretty esoteric oh yeah like poetry
right you know how you go down and watch
the poetry and stuff yeah exactly you
know that's that's the kind of thing it
just it has its own it's own fan base
yeah yeah super people are super into
chamber music yeah I love chamber music
I'm really into it I like it too
actually oh it's the best my my daughter
like I said was a ballerina and um my
oldest daughter and so I would go to
dance
things and uh some of them I didn't know
what was happening it was torture right
yeah some of them were were torture some
of the stuff kid concerts are brutal kid
Sports is brutal too yeah some of these
weren't kids you know I mean eventually
I was getting roped into doing like
whatever
some real cultured activities and wasn't
Landing with me it
you no no you're not a bad person you're
Flesh and Blood
Joo awesome any other ones that's it for
now any closing thoughts Arthur yeah you
know it's like it a lot of people always
ask you know what's the what's the one
thing to remember and so I was thinking
what's the one thing there's a study
that we've done at Harvard called the
Harvard study of adult development
that's that tracked men from the late
1930s until death and then their kids
and then their spouses and it matched up
you know students at Harvard with people
who didn't go to college so it's Soo
economically diverse and they looked at
all the things they did over the course
of their lives that helped them end up
happy and healthy at the end of the Liv
so it's a crystal ball you know what do
they do and some of it's you know pretty
obvious diet and exercise and smoking
and drinking they didn't drink or drank
very moderately they didn't smoke or
they quit early they they exercised but
not to the point where they neglected
their families and they they they kept a
healthy body weight but they didn't do
yo-yo dieting okay right but then they
had a way to deal with their problems
cuz everybody's got problems they had a
way to deal with it like talking to
friends or whatever it happened to be
they had a technique for dealing with
their worries and problems so it didn't
build up they were lifelong Learners and
that was really good but the one the one
of the seven practices that mattered the
most by far is that they had close
loving relationships you know it was
they either had a a a marriage that they
could count on or they or they had
really close personal friends or even
better both is what it came down to and
the the conclusion of that is that
happiness is Love full stop and so
that's really the one thing to remember
when you when you when you don't know
what to do go love somebody when you
don't know what to say tell somebody
perhaps not so many words I love you
when you're when you're thinking of
thoughts that are destructive turn your
thoughts to what you love love will
bring you happiness and that's the one
thing we can actually all count on it's
the one thing that really matters in our
lives it's the one thing that gives us
all a better future so the last word is
basically this you don't know what to do
love
more right on well thanks for joining us
thanks for coming down thanks for your
Lessons Learned and thanks for sharing
your
methodologies and thanks for helping
people live better happier lives
likewise jao you're doing a great
service for a lot of people and I'm
delighted to be some small part of it
today right on appreciate it thanks
thank
you and with that Arthur C Brooks has
left the
building
happiness you seem to like that I could
see I I look over at you you're into it
yeah yeah I think um you know I think
you know this where I do enjoy the like
finding out how things work you know
especially if they're just not that real
simple to to figure out and I think
that's another one especially those kind
of riddle ones cuz it's like a riddle
right for this one where it's like it's
not like the direct easy obvious answer
so you be like hey what's the key to
happiness oh suffering and misery you
know like it doesn't seem real it's like
counterintuitive a lot of this stuff so
it becomes interesting I
think well there you go uh get the books
you guys know the deal try and be
happier choose to be happier that's kind
of what I feel like you can be miserable
or you can be happy that might be some
look you're going through basic SEAL
training you're young like I was and you
could you're look you're going to be wet
you're going to be
cold and you can be wet cold and
miserable which is what they tell you're
going to be or you can be wet cold and
kind of happy about the whole scenario
yeah so I'm going to be happy yeah have
fun with it at a minimum so even when
you choose when you're not they see it
who the instructors you know what I mean
Oh you mean if you're or your teammates
like your platoon mates they're like oh
Eko is looking like he's hating life
right now yeah that's kind of not cool
it's not cool don't want to give off
that no let's be happy and then even if
you are um happy during the suffering
when the suffering is over it's not like
the happiness goes away or nothing it
gets better actually for real now you
got the memory of happiness and you got
current
happiness
but
clearly uh key components here we talked
about these and it's always surprising
right and in in again in the book it's
like if you do what if you do what makes
you happy you're going to end up not
happy you know this is like a lack of
discipline right this is the freedom
equaling
slavery as opposed to discipline equals
Freedom so that's what we got to do well
you made it you made a really good point
long time ago and actually it's it was
such a good point and so simple and so
easy to understand that I tell my kids
this all the time and you say pay now or
pay later mhm so it's like hey it's
going to be easy or and and it's going
to be hard you just choose when you know
so you want to do the pay the pay is a
hard it's hard to pay it's easy to
collect right so if you collect now
you're going to pay later it's going to
be way junker in my opinion and I
explain why you know a lot of it you
know even if you talk about working out
where it's like hey I'd rather pay now
she's like oh working out is hard I was
like yeah working out is hard but I'll
tell you what's harder being weak tell
you what's harder when you're thinking
when you know when it's time to go to
the beach or the pool or whatever and
then you got to think in your anxiety
because how does my body look or
something like this you know that's way
harder then working out anyway pay now
pay later that's a good one I recommend
we pay now yep pay now health and
discipline it's going to help you uh
deaf reset we got coming
Y and you just made a You made a video
got a uh what is it a preview of the
launch video uh they call it a warning
order iess War yeah so this is the thing
so
for the de reset last year was like like
January 1 oh yeah here you go jump into
it Leif was saying because I I was
telling Leif and the EF team I was like
Hey listen I'm trying to give people a
heads up for de reset because normally
it's like oh it's a New Year's
resolution wait why don't you just start
now right which I've said that kind of
thing like don't wait for a New Year's
resolution to start now here's the thing
death reset starts January 1st if you're
not ready for it it's going to hurt
you're going to pay later yeah so put
some investment in out Leif made the
point that like last year's de reset he
got he he got hurt like I don't know a
week into it he had to stand down what
cuz he went hard out the gate went hard
so what I'm saying is prepare for de
reset now that means you should be
waking up a little bit earlier you
should definitely start working out now
you should get things staged you should
be prepared don't go cold into de reset
you don't want none of that you won't
make it you won't make it you won't be
able to keep it up so de resets coming
January 1 prepare for it now we got
workouts and fitness with Jason kipa we
got leadership training with Echelon
front we got discipline directives from
me and we got fuel obviously Joo fuel so
we got a bunch of really good things
going to help a lot of people get back
on the path set the trajectory of your
life correct the trajectory of your life
improve the trajectory of your life
because that's weird that trajectory
word means a lot it's like you're just
heading in a direction why not make sure
that you're heading in the right
direction in a positive direction that's
what your trajectory is and de reset
will help reset that trajectory and make
it better so that's what we're doing um
Joo fuel you're going to want some Joo
fuel for this Evolution for sure you're
going to want some MK cuz you're going
to need some to rebuild you're going to
want some hydration cuz you're going to
sweat you got that Joo hydrate we got
greens joint Warfare for sure super kill
just Mulk just the whole nine yards
that's what we're doing go to joof
fuel.com and get what you need to be
ready to be better to be
prepared you can order it from joof
fuel.com or you can get it from the
Vitamin Shop you can get it from WWA you
can get it from GNC military
commissaries AP tanford death Dash
stores in Maryland wake Fern shopright
HB down in
teos Meyer Harris Teeter Lifetime
Fitness Shields small gyms all over the
place Jiu-Jitsu gyms CrossFit Gyms
powerlifting gyms globo gyms if you're
going to one of those if you own one of
those and you want to sell joof fuel go
to JF sales joof fuel.com and get some
of that so there you go true joof
field.com it's true also origin USA
don't forget about that is origin giving
away I think they might be giving away a
gift card right for the de reset
probably yeah I think so it's a good
deal because they got some good stuff
americanmade stuff by the way I was
wearing the you know the the I don't
know what would you call it the moisture
wicking hoodie oh yeah I don't know the
names Pete always has these cool names
for him but nonetheless many compliments
on that one that's a good one oh yeah
all American made did I mention that so
I believe you're talking about the tetr
loock yeah it's very possible yeah H
yeah origin usa.com get some cool stuff
to wear get stuff that's made in America
look man that's what we're
doing we're not we're not we're not
supporting communism that doesn't help
people be happy we you go look at the
Communist pictures you see any happiness
over there you're not going to see it
see happiness where there's Freedom so
origin usa.com brings Freedom brings
happiness to the world go get it that's
what we're doing it's true also Joor if
you want to if you want to represent on
this path whether it's de reset or or
Beyond you know represent discipline
equals Freedom that's you go to Jo
store.com that's where you get your
shirts and hats hoodies all kinds of
merch anyway good stuff on there also
shirt Locker new design shirt every
month it's a subscription kind of thing
people seem to like it go on there check
it out tell me what you think you think
it's cool go subscribe to that one it's
a good one everything shos store.com uh
if you need steak which you probably do
check out Primal beef.com check out
Colorado AutoCraft beef.com the best
steak delivered to your house that's
what we're doing check those out also
subscribe to the podcast also check out
Joo underground.com it's a little we're
about to record one of those when we get
done here so that's what we do ajacent
material we also answer questions all
the time that you email in so check out
Joo underground.com also YouTube
subscribe to that psychological warfare
Flipside canvas.com Dakota Meer making
cool stuff to hang on your wall we got a
bunch of books obviously bunch books uh
love your enemies by Arthur C Brooks
build the life you want by Arthur C
Brooks and Oprah
Winfrey um strength to strength he's got
a bunch of books so check those out and
then of course I've written a bunch of
books too so you might want to check
those out they're out there especially
check out the kids books like you don't
need to be 38 when you learn these
lessons you can learn them when you're
five maybe seven way of the warrior kid
go get those books for the kids in your
neighborhood you got that neighbor
across the street he's kind of a
delinquent seems a little little bit
he's 9 years old he's hucking rocks at
trees and stuff yes look I was hucking
rocks at trees you know what I mean you
can just let him continue to Huck rocks
at trees next thing he escalates to like
mailboxes then he's going Vehicles then
he's you know see you see what I'm going
with this bad bad
scene Warrior kid get him on the right
path that's what we're doing also
Echelon front we have a leadership
consultancy go to Echelon front.com for
details on that that's do we work with
companies we Square them away we help
them
unify their
leadership so if you need help inside
your organization go to ashon front.com
you can come to one of our Live Events
as well it's all there ashon front.com
we also have online training online Life
Training is what it is look it's it's
kind of represented as leadership
training but what is leadership training
leadership is how you interact with
other human beings your friends your
family your husband your wife your kids
and everybody that you work with and the
better you are with leadership skills
the better you're going to be as a human
being so go to extrem ownership. comom
check out our courses there also if you
want to help service members active and
retired you want to help their families
gold star families check out Mark Lee's
mom mama Lee She's Got an amazing
charity organization if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
America's Mighty warriors.org
also heroes and horses. org we got Micah
think taking taking our First Responders
and our veterans up into the mountains
where they get lost so they can get
found Heroes and horses. org also Jimmy
May's got his organization beyond the
brotherhood. org so connect with those
to help out and if you want to connect
with Arthur once again Arthur brooks.com
he's got Twitter Arthur Brooks he's got
Instagram Arthur C Brooks YouTube Arthur
brooks1 123 and Facebook's Arthur Brooks
Brooks Echo is at Echo Charles I'm at
Joo willink just be careful if you go to
connect with us looking for happiness
you're not going to find it there don't
go there looking for
happiness all you're going to find is an
algorithm that's going to grab you by
the jugular and kill you so be
careful thanks once again to all of the
military personnel out there around the
world right now keeping us safe and
secure we get to do every day what we do
because of the sacrifices that you make
and we are grateful same goes to our
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
all First Responders thank you for
keeping us safe and secure here at
home and everyone else out
there happiness is not found by doing
what is easy or what feels good in the
moment at least not long-term lasting
happiness that's not what we're going
for sure you can go feel good right now
by eating a donut or having a drink an
alcoholic drink or watching another
Netflix program or scrolling through
your social media you can do those
things but it's not going to give you
the
longterm happiness that you're looking
for I say you start with helping others
working hard and doing the right things
for the right
reasons and what I mean that by that is
basically if you want to be happy I
recommend that you go out there and get
after it and until next time Zeo and Joo
out